WE THE SENATE BUDGET FISCAL
REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE WILL
NOW COME TO ORDER GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE. AS WE CONTINUE TO TAKE
SOME PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE
ONGOING COVERT NINETEEN RISKS
THE SENATE CONTINUES TO WELCOME
THE PUBLIC AND HAS PROVIDED
ACCESS TO BOTH IN PERSON AND
TELECONFERENCING TO THE PATIENT
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT FOR
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE.
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE SIX
THREE AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
SEVEN SIX TWO TWO FOUR SIX TWO.
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THAT HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY- I
DON'T EXPECT THIS BUT ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTION NEEDED WE ARE HOLDING
OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN
THE- STREET BUILDING I ASK ALL
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE. BE
PRESENT SO WE CAN ESTABLISH
QUORUM THOSE PROVIDING TESTIMONY
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
ALSO PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR
OUR REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE
MUTE YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS
THIS WILL GREATLY AID IN
ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. I ASK THAT EVERY TIME
YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZE THAT
YOU USE THE QUOTE UNQUOTE RAISE
YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM
EACH TIME YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK A POP UP WINDOW WILL
APPEAR ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO UN MUTE. PLEASE SELECT ON
MUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING
R. I. T. PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU
BACK ON MUTE WHEN YOUR- READ. AS
PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN
ON THE SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME
AND THEN YOU'RE READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
HEARING ROOM TO THE EXTENT THE
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW. AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY- WE WILL BE DISCUSSING ALL
THE ISSUES LISTED IN THE
DISCUSSION SECTION OF THE AGENDA
TOGETHER AND PUBLIC COMMENT.
WILL BE AT THE END OF ALL OF THE
ISSUES. FLOW WE WILL NOW GET
STARTED- GOOD MORNING DOCTOR
BACK BILL- WE WILL NOW GET
STARTED WITH ISSUE ONE WHICH IS
LEGAL AID PROPOSALS AND- WE HAVE
FIRST A PRESENTATION BY THE L.
A. O. IS THAT MISLI. YES GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR- ANNUALLY
WITH THE L. A. L. COMMITTEE
STAFF HAS ASKED US TO INTRODUCE
THE ITEM AND PROVIDE A LITTLE
BIT OF BACKGROUND INFORMATION TO
FRAME YOUR DISCUSSION TODAY.
ANNOUNCED SENATE IS CURRENTLY
CONSIDERING POLLS TO INCREASE
LEGAL AID ASSISTANCE INCLUDING
ADDITIONAL LEGAL AID FUNDING FOR
ADDICTION AND DEBT CONSUMER
CASES AS WELL AS CREATING A LOAN
REPAYMENT PROGRAM FOR LEGAL AID
LAWYERS. AS NOTED IN YOUR AGENDA
ONE MAJOR SOURCE OF STATE
FUNDING TO SUPPORT LEGAL AID
COMES THROUGH THE STATE'S EQUAL
ACCESS PROGRAM THAT RECEIVES
BOTH GENERAL FUND AND CIVIL
FILING FEES SUPPORT. SO ONGOING
FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAM OR FIND
WAS ABOUT TWENTY SIX MILLION IN
TWENTY EIGHT NINETEEN AND WILL
BE ABOUT FORTY SIX MILLION IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE.
ON TOP OF THIS- SINCE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
LIMITED TERM FUNDING WAS ALSO
PROVIDED FROM VARIOUS SOURCES
SUCH AS FEDERAL FINES-
SPECIFICALLY FOR- EVICTION CASES
. SO IN TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE THE TOTAL FUNDING FOR THIS
PROGRAM IS CURRENTLY PROPOSED TO
BE ABOUT SIXTY FIVE MILLION IN
TOTAL FORTY SIX MILLION AN ON
GOING FUNDING AND TWENTY MILLION
IN LIMITED TERM MONEY. THANK YOU
. THANK YOU. OF WILL NOW. NEXT
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM SELENA
COPELAND FROM THE LEGAL AID
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA. THIS
COPELAND. MORNING ADAM CHAIR AND
OTHER MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS CELINA COPELAND AND
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
LEGALLY DISSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
MY ORGANIZATION WAS FOUNDED SOON
AFTER THIS LEGISLATURE CREATED
THAT CALIFORNIA'S INTEREST ON
LAWYER TRUST ACCOUNTS PROGRAM
THE I ALSO PROGRAM IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY ONE FOR FORTY YEARS WE'VE
WORKED WITH LEGAL AID PROGRAMS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THE
LEGISLATURE THE COURTS IN THE
STATE BAR WITH THE GOAL OF
ENSURING THAT LOW INCOME PEOPLE
HAVE ACCESS TO LEGAL AID
ATTORNEY. FOR THE RECENTLY
RELEASED NOT JUST GOT STUDY
SHOWS THAT 74% OF LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS EXPERIENCED. THE
LEGAL PROBLEM IN A LOT. 92% OF
THE INCOME. WITH THE SYSTEM.
CIVIL LEGAL PROBLEMS DO NOT GET
ANY OR ENOUGH LEGAL HELP.
HEARING ASSIST INCLUDES MORE
INFORMATION JUSTICE GOT STUDY
BUT THE MOST IMPORTANT TAKE
AWAYS ARE THE MOST COMMON LEGAL
CHALLENGES. FOR LOW INCOME
PEOPLE. ANYWHERE CONSUMER ISSUES
50% OF ALL INCOME HOUSEHOLD HOW
TO CONSUMER DEBT PROBLEM. I'M
HEALTHCARE 39% OF HOUSEHOLDS HOW
TO HELP YOUR PROBLEM INCOME
MAINTENANCE THAT INCLUDES ACCESS
TO PUBLIC BENEFITS 34% AND
HOUSING THAT WAS 33% OF LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS ACROSS AMERICA
HAD A HOUSING PROBLEM. THE STUDY
THE NATIONAL REFLECTS WHAT WE
SEE HERE IN CALIFORNIA LOW
INCOME PEOPLE CONTINUE TO
STRUGGLE TO PAY THEIR RENT. TAKE
CARE OF THEIR HEALTH ACCESS
PUBLIC BENEFITS AND MANAGE
CRUSHING PERSONAL DEBT. I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR THE ONE TIME
INCREASE NICKEL ACCESS FROM LAST
YEAR ISN'T IT IS MISLEAD SHARED
HER REPORT HE WALKS AS FUN AS
THE PRIMARY VEHICLE FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO FIND
LEGAL SERVICES TO THE POOR. THIS
INCREASE WAS WELL TIMED
ORGANISING. LARGE NUMBERS OF
PEOPLE COMING TO OFFICES. WOULD
NEVER END. NEEDING LEGAL BEFORE
THE CADILLAC. I THE SAME TIME.
THE INTEREST ON LAWYER TRUST
ACCOUNT INTEREST RATES WERE
REVENUE DROPPED. DUE TO THE
CRASH IN THE INTEREST RATES
ACROSS OUR COUNTRY. WHAT IS YOUR
TWO QUICK EXAMPLES OF HOW THE
INCREASE IN FUNDING HAS BEEN
YEARS. THE LOS ANGELES INTERLINE
JUSTICE USE THEIR INCREASE TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE CRITICAL
IMMIGRATION SERVICES. TO
SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SEXUAL ASSAULT AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. IN ONE CASE THEY
HELPED AN EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD
SURVIVOR OF SEXUAL ASSAULT THERE
YOU VISA. WHICH ALLOWED HER TO
GET A WORK PERMIT. IMPORTANTLY
HER NEW STATUS EXTENDED
PROTECTIONS ARE FAMILY TO HER
TWO PARENTS AND THREE SIBLINGS.
AND NOW THERE'S AN ENTIRE FAMILY
GAINING ELIGIBILITY FOR WORK
AUTHORIZATION AND PROTECTION
FROM REMOVAL AND FAMILY
STABILITY DUE TO THIS YOUNG
WOMAN'S BRAVE DECISION TO COME
FORWARD. ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF HOW
ORGANISED ARE USING INCREASE. IS
PROPHETICALLY SERVICES MARTINEZ
. THEY SURE THAT FIRST AN IMP OF
ENQUIRIES FOR LOW WAGE.
REQUIREMENTS WITH UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE ISSUES DURING THE
PANDEMIC. IN RESPONSE BETTER
DEVELOPED AN EXPERTISE AND
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE. CLAIMS
AND APPEALS. THERE'S NOT BEGIN
CONDUCTING INTAKES I REALLY
SCHEDULE CLINIC. IS STAFF OR NOT
CONDUCTING INTAKES NOT ONLY ON
THE REGULAR WAGE HOUR MATTERS.
BUT ALSO HEALTH AND SAFETY AND
UNEMPLOYMENT ISSUES THROUGHOUT
THE THROUGHOUT THE CLINIC. WHICH
RESULTED IN IN THEM INCREASING.
THEIR CLINIC. MARCH OF. THEY RAN
A ONCE IN. AT THE HEIGHT OF THE
PANDEMIC THERE RUNNING THREE
TIMES A WEEK. WHILE GRIPPING THE
WAY OF LOS PROVIDED IN THIS
FUNDING TO COVER THAT EXPANSION
THAT WAS A ONE TIME CAPACITY
GRANT FUNDING. AND THE ONLY WAY
THE BEEN ABLE TO CONTINUE THAT
SERVICES THE SERVICES IS THROUGH
THE INCREASE IN CLOCKS US FINE.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO THE SPENDING
IS STABLE WHICH IS WHY WE'RE
ASKING TO CONTINUE THE ONE TIME
INCREASE OF THIRTY MILLION FROM
LAST YEAR. TO ONGOING HERE. AS
YOU SEE IN STOCK ANALYSIS THE
NEED IS STILL GREAT PARTICULARLY
AS A RESULT OF THE LONG TERM
FINANCIAL IMPACTS OF COVERAGE.
AND WE NEED TO PRESERVE THESE
IMPORTANT PROGRAMS. THERE IS A
NEED. THE FUNDING HOUSING
CONSUMER LEGAL SERVICES AS WELL
AS YOUR NATIONAL JUSTICE GOT
STUDY WHICH MATCHES WHAT WE HEAR
IN THE COMMUNITY OR HOUSING FOR
EXAMPLE THE CONTINUES TO BE A
NEED TO INCREASE SERVICES FOR
EVICTING DEFENSE AND TEN
EDUCATION WE HAVE STARTED THE
LEGALLY COMMUNITY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AN ORGANIZATION SAID
THAT THEIR CURRENT FUNDING GAP
FUNDING THEY COULD SPEND RIGHT
AWAY TO INCREASE SERVICES WAS
JUST OVER A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS. FOR A THREE YEAR GRANT
AND THIS FIGURE DOES NOT INCLUDE
WHAT THE NON LEGAL COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS BELIEVE THEY
CAN USE RIGHT AWAY TO EIGHT IN
TEN OUTREACH AND EDUCATION
EFFORTS IN PART. PRETTY NATIONAL
JUSTICE A RESULT OF FOR THREE
PER OF LOS RENT HOUSEHOLD
EXPERIENCES OF CROSS LATEST
MEETING SERVICES BEFORE HAVE A
MASSIVE INCREASE HOUSING
INSTABILITY IN OUR STATE AND
AGAIN AN EXAMPLE OF HOW
ORGANIZATIONS ARE I'M DOING
HOUSING LEGAL SERVICES FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSISTANCE. THE
MULTIPLE TENANTS WERE VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN ONE CASE
THEY HAVE TO TENANTS WHO'VE BEEN
UNLAWFULLY LOCKED OUT OF HER
HOME AFTER THE LANDLORD
APARTMENT COMPLEX EVICTED HER ON
THE BASIS OF THE DOMESTIC BOX
INSTEAD INCIDENT. WITH HER MUSIC
WAS SENTENCED TO TEN YEARS.
EARLY GOT A DEFAULT JUDGMENT SET
ASIDE AND IT WAS ABLE TO RETURN
HOME. SO THE TENANT AND HER FOR
MINOR CHILDREN REMAIN HOUSE
TODAY. HOW MANY EXAMPLES WHICH I
CAN SHARE WITH BUDGET STAFF WERE
CIVIL WHERE LEGALLY PROBLEM HAD
TO STEP LEGAL AID PROGRAM HAD TO
STEP IN AND ENFORCE THE EVICTION
PROTECTION RIGHTS. THAT YOU
CREATED DURING THE COVER
NINETEEN CONDEMNING. WE'RE EVEN
LOCAL COURTS DID NOT UNDERSTAND
THEIR OBLIGATION TO STOP
LOCKOUTS WHEN EMERGENCY RENTAL
PROGRAM APPLICATION HAS BEEN
APPROVED. TURNING VERY BRIEFLY
TO CONSUMER DEBT ISSUES THE
LARGEST NEED IN THE NATIONAL
STUDY. IN ORDER TO HELP PEOPLE
FINANCIALLY IMPACTED BY JOB LOSS
INCREASED DEBT WE NEED DEDICATED
MULTI YEAR FUNDING TO ENCOURAGE
THE CREATION AND EXPANSION. OF
CONSUMER DEBT. LEGAL SERVICES A
LEGAL AID ORGANIZATION. WITH
ALLOCATION. IN ONE TIME FUNDING
OVER THREE YEARS IS THE RIGHT
AMOUNT TO INCUBATE THIS PROGRAM
IN CRITICAL CORPORATE LEGAL AID
ATTORNEYS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
WE CAN HELP PEOPLE NAVIGATE
CHALLENGING MEDICAL DEBT AND
CREDIT CARD DEBT. THAT LARGELY
CAME ABOUT BECAUSE OF CODE
RELATED JOB LOSS. ON WHAT DO YOU
WANT TO SPEND GRANT G. MENTAL
ADVOCACY SERVICES USED THEIR
EQUAL ACCESS FUND GRANT TO FUND
A CONSUMER FINANCE PROGRAM FOR
LOW INCOME PEOPLE WITH MENTAL
HEALTH DISABILITIES. THE
PROGRAMS ARE CONCERTS CLIENTS
WHO DO CREDIT REPORTING ERRORS
HAD DIFFICULTY OBTAINING WORK
AND IT DIFFICULTY SECURING
HOPPING. THEY ALSO HELP COMBAT
FINANCIAL EXPLOITATION AND
STANDS. IN HOUSING DEDICATED
FUNDING OR. CONTINUE AND EXPAND
THIS WORK. NOT JUST ONE LAST
CONSUMER EXAMPLE. FROM COMMUNITY
LEE AID SO WOULD YOU AND ONCE
LOS CA. MEDICAL WAS COURSE INTO
K. HER YOU SUPPOSE. JUST SEVERAL
GOOD. WERE SHE WAS ORDERED TO
PURCHASE HANDGUNS RIFLES AND
AMMUNITIONS WITH HER CREDIT
CARD. AFTER THE PURCHASES WHICH
TOTALED SIX SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS
SHE FOUND HERSELF WITH A DEAD
SHE COULDN'T HANDLE AND WAS
CONSEQUENTLY SUIT. TAKING THE
CASE COMMUNITY LEGAL AID SOMEHOW
ATTORNEY ARGUED THAT THE SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS WAS COERCED
DEBT. CITING HER ABUSIVE
HUSBANDS BEHAVIOR. PROVIDE
IMPROVED OPPOSING COUNSEL HOW
MUCH YOUR BEFORE THE- OF THE
GUNS AND HISTORY HER USE OF THE
CREDIT CARD AND HER GOOD
PAYMENTS. IT'S THE CONTRAST
BETWEEN HER. THE CARD AND THE
UNUSUAL SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS
CHARGE. THANKFULLY THE CASE WAS
SETTLED FOR JUST ABOUT TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS WHICH IS WHAT
SHE OR PRIOR TO THE GUN
PURCHASES. AND THE CREDIT CARD
COMPANY ALLOWED HER TO PAY OFF
THE SETTLEMENT BE BE A MONTHLY
PAYMENTS ONLY EIGHTY SEVEN
DOLLARS A MONTH. THE CLIENT WHO
HAS FILED FOR DIVORCE PRESENTLY
LIVES ON HER OWN AND HAS CUSTODY
OF HER DAUGHTERS. SO ALL THESE
INCREASES LEGALLY FUNDING MAKE
AN ENORMOUS IMPACT ON THE LEGAL
AID ORGANIZATIONS CAN ACCOMPLISH
FOR YOUR CONSTITUENTS. WITH THE
INVESTMENTS TO START ABOUT. IT
ORGANIZATIONS CAN CONTINUE TO
MAKE SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCES IN
OUR COMMUNITY AND A CONTACT.
NUMBER. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MUST GO. VERY MUCH. THAT WAS
VERY INSIDE. ON AN ABI VERY. TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT WAS GOING ON OUT
THERE AS FAR AS LEGAL SERVICES
THAT ARE NEEDED. ON NEXT WE WILL
HEAR FROM JACK LONDON FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ACCESS TO JUSTICE
COMMISSION. THANK YOU CENTER MY
NAME IS JACK LONDON. I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACCESS TO JUSTICE
COMMISSION. LAST YEAR YOU
APPROPRIATED FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR US TO MAKE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND INNOVATION
GRANTS TO LEGAL AID NON PROFITS
. RECEIVE ALMOST TEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN REQUESTS. WE'RE ABLE
TO AWARD FORTY SEVEN GRANTS TO
PROGRAM STRUCK CALIFORNIA THIRTY
TWO FOUR RURAL COMMUNITIES
THIRTY SIX TO SERVE IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES. TWENTY FOUR TO FORM
PARTNERSHIPS WITH COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS. THESE ARE
RAMPS SHOULD CONTINUE AND IF
POSSIBLE THEY SHOULD INCREASE.
OUR INFRASTRUCTURE GRANTS ALLOW
MANY LEGAL AND NON PROFITS TO
PROVIDE TECHNOLOGY FOR REMOTE
SERVICES TO CLARK'S. TO PROVIDE
MULTI LANGUAGE ONLINE SERVICES
AND UPDATE OBSOLETE SYSTEMS. LET
ME GIVE YOU THREE WE GIVE YOU
TWO EXAMPLES OF INNOVATION.
NEIGHBORHOOD LEGAL SERVICES OF
L. A. COUNTY AND THREE PARTNERS
ARE DEVELOPING A NEW SYSTEM THAT
USES TACTIC. TO GET CLIENT
FEEDBACK AND ASSESSMENTS OF CASE
OUTCOMES AND IMPACT. OUR MOST
CLIENTS HAVE CELL PHONES AND IT
TURNS OUT THE RATES OF
PARTICIPATION ARE VERY HIGH.
THIS WILL GIVE US EXTREMELY
VALUABLE INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT
SERVICES WORK BEST FOR CLIENTS.
ANOTHER INNOVATION IS BY
VETERANS LEGAL INSTITUTE IT'S
CREATING A LIBRARY OF KNOW YOUR
RIGHTS VIDEOS FOR VETERANS ON
SEVERAL AREAS OF LAWS WITH
SPECIAL PROTECTIONS. THIS IS
MONEY WELL SPENT AND WE'RE HAPPY
THAT WE'LL CONTINUE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE IF POSSIBLE INCREASE. BUT
LET ME TELL YOU ABOUT ANOTHER-
NEED. AND THAT IS. THERE IS A
CRISIS IN RECRUITING AND
RETAINING LAWYERS FOR LEGAL AID
NON PROFITS AND HELPFUL. RIGHT
NOW THERE IS ONE LEGAL AID
LAWYER FOR EVERY SEVEN THOUSAND.
ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIANS. WHAT'S
WORSE R. A RECENT ABA SURVEY
SHOWED THAT ONE THIRD OF LAWYERS
EMPLOYED AT LEGAL AID
ORGANIZATIONS LEFT THEIR JOBS
EVERY TWO WEEKS. AND THAT WAS
BEFORE THE CURRENT TIGHT JOB
MARKET. LOW PAY AND HIGH STUDENT
LOAN PAYMENT OBLIGATIONS WITH
THE MAIN RESULTS WE PROPOSE THAT
THE STATE SHOULD PROVIDE TEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN CONTINUING
ANNUAL FUNDING FOR A STUDENT
LOAN REPAYMENT ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM FOR LAWYERS WHO SERVE
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS WHILE
WORKING AT LEGAL AID NON PROFITS
. STUDENT LOAN DEBT IS ALSO A
BARRIER TO DIVERSITY IN LEGAL
AID LGAL AID LAWYERS SHOULD
REFLECT THE DIVERSITY OF THE
COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE THAT'S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. I'D LIKE TO
KNOW AND BLACK LAW STUDENTS HAVE
TO BORROW MORE FOR THEIR
EDUCATION THEIR LOAN BALANCES
ARE 20% OR MORE HIGHER. THAN ONE
STUDENTS LAW STUDENTS ACCORDING
Y. LAS STUDENTS ACCORDING TO THE
AMERICAN BAR ASSOCIATION. WITH
CONTINUING FUNDING OF TEN
MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR. MOST
IF NOT ALL STUDENT LOAN PAYMENTS
FOR CALIFORNIA LEGAL AID LAWYERS
COULD BE COVERED FOR AS LONG AS
THEY REMAIN IN LEGAL AID JOCKS.
THE BENEFITS WOULD BE STRUCTURED
ON A TAX EXEMPT BASIS. IT WOULD
NOT BE TAXED FOR THE BENEFIT
THEY RECEIVED THIS MAKES THAT IT
MF VERY EFFICIENT USE OF THE
MONEY. IT WOULD BE A POWERFUL
SUPPORT FOR RECRUITMENT
RETENTION AND WOULD MAKE
POSSIBLE A MORE DIVERSE LEGAL
AID WORKER FORCE. I STAY IN
LEGAL AID FOR TEN YEARS LAWYERS
CAN ALSO GET PUBLIC SERVICE LOAN
FORGIVENESS FROM THE US
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. ACCESS
COMMISSION IS PROVIDING THIS
YEAR TRAINING FOR LAWYERS ABOUT
HOW TO QUALIFY FOR THE NEWLY
REDESIGNED PUBLIC SERVICE LOAN
FORGIVENESS PROGRAM M. FOR HOW
TO GO BACK AND CORRECT-
DOCUMENTATION PROBLEMS IN THE
PAST. THIS IS A FEDERAL PROGRAM
BUT IT WORKS HAND IN HAND WITH
THE POWER PROPOSED LOAN
REPAYMENT PROGRAM WITH PAYMENT
PROGRAM WILL COVER HER. LOAN
PAYMENT OBLIGATIONS WHILE
LAWYERS STAY IN THEIR LEGAL AID
JOBS IT'S A POWERFUL TOOL FOR
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION THE
CITIZENSHIP USE OF THE MONEY.
AND IF WHERE IS STABLE AID JOBS
FOR TEN YEARS THE LOAN REPAYMENT
THROUGH THIS PROGRAM WILL
QUALIFY FOR FEDERAL. LOAN
FORGIVENESS AS WELL SO THEIR
BALANCE WILL GO AWAY AFTER TEN
YEARS. AND THEIR PAYMENTS WILL
BE COVERED. THIS IS HOW NEED
IT'S A- EFFICIENT. WE HAVE AN
ANSWER QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
MISTER LONDON GREAT GREAT
EXAMPLES- THAT MAKES IT PRETTY
CLEAR CRYSTAL CLEAR HERE. OF
WILL WILL COME BACK FOR A
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE I
HAVE A COUPLE OF. QUESTIONS- YOU
BOTH GAVE- MISTER LONDON AND
MISS COPLAND YOU BOTH GAVE
REALLY GREAT EXAMPLES OF HOW.
WHAT IS GOING ON RIGHT NOW WITH
CONSUMER DEBT AND THE NEED FOR-
AND ACTUALLY MENTIONED A NUMBER
OF AREAS WERE THAT HAVE LED TO
LEGAL PROBLEMS. AND OF COURSE
THE NEED TO HIRE AND RETAIN-
LEGAL AID ATTORNEYS. WITH
REGARDS TO OF- THE LEGAL OF.
LET'S SEE THE CONSUMER OF DEBT
THAT'S DO YOU SEE THAT THAT IS
THERE ANY PROGRAM THAT WE HAVE
DONE THAT WILL HELP ADDRESS THAT
OF CONSUMER DEBT- ANY BIG
SHOULDN'T CASES- DO YOU SEE IT-
CHANGING- YOU KNOW AS WE RETURN
TO QUOTE UNQUOTE MORE AND MORE
NORMAL ANA WHAT WHAT'S YOUR
SENSE OF HOW IT'S MOVING AND
INTO THIS NEW PHASE OF THE
PANDEMIC. MAY BE MISSED COPELAND
BOTH OF YOU MS COPELAND YOU
COULD START. IT HAPPENS HERE
AND- ALSO BELIEVE TEMPERAMENT
HE'S LATER ON THE AGENDA WILL
HAVE SOME THOUGHTS ON THIS AS
WELL. WHEN I THINK. ESPECIALLY
IN IN CASES OF CONSUMER DEBT
LEGAL SERVICES AND EVICTION
PREVENTION AND CONVICTION AND
CONTAIN EDUCATION ISSUES NOW
IT'S JUST A CRITICAL TIME
BECAUSE OF CODE RELATED JOB LOSS
I THINK THAT WE MAY SEE AND
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT IMPACTS
PEOPLE FIVE YEARS FROM NOW. BUT
NOW I JUST FEEL THAT ESPECIALLY
UNPRECEDENTED SO MANY HOUSEHOLDS
ARE IN CALIFORNIA YOU ARE RENTER
HOUSEHOLDS WHO ARE UNABLE TO PAY
ALL OR A PORTION OF THEIR RENT
FOR TIME AND EVERYONE STILL KIND
OF. DIG THEMSELVES OUT OF WHAT
WE SAW IN PRIOR DISASTERS MAKING
HURRICANES AND TORNADOES AND
FLOODS WHERE A LOT OF PEOPLE
WERE ABLE TO BORROW FROM
FAMILIES OR FROM FRIENDS OR
BEING ABLE TO TEMPORARILY USE
CREDIT CARDS. BUT WHEN SO MUCH
OF OUR SOCIETY IS IMPACTED
ESPECIALLY LOWER INCOME
CALIFORNIA'S ARE IMPACTED BY
THIS THE EXHAUST WHILE THE OTHER
RESOURCES SO I THINK WE PROBABLY
WILL SEE A LONG TAIL OF THESE
ISSUES FOR SEVERAL YEARS. AND
HOPEFULLY AS WE RECOVER- MAYBE
THAT WOULD NOT BE MORE
PROTECTIONS THAT YOU CREATE IN
CALIFORNIA THAT CAN PROTECT
PEOPLE IN THE LONGER RUN. I
THINK THIS IS NOT IT IS A ONE
TIME NEED. IT'S NOT GONNA BE
OVER NEXT YEAR. YEAH ANY
THOUGHTS LEARNED. THANKS THANK
YOU CENTER I'M GONNA USE A
STYLUS. I'M SORRY I DIDN'T HEAR
YOU. I'M GONNA LEAVE THIS TO MR
RAHMAN AND OTHERS WHO WILL SPEAK
TO WORK ON CAN YOU THAT OKAY
THANK YOU AND THEN- I THINK MR-
LONDON YOU DID TALK ABOUT THE-
ATTORNEYS HE SAID I THINK YOU
SAID SOMETHING LIKE A THIRD OF
ATTORNEYS HAVE LEFT. AND YOU
ATTRIBUTED. TO COLLEGE DEBT AND
ONE OTHER ITEM THAT I DIDN'T
CATCH. WELL PAY SENATOR WE DID A
SURVEY WITH THE STATE BAR LAST
YEAR AND FOUND THAT THE AVERAGE
LEGAL AID SALARY AT ANY. LEVEL
OF SENIORITY IS AT LEAST TWELVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS LOWER THAN THE
BOTTOM OF THE RANGE OF
GOVERNMENT ATTORNEYS WORKING FOR
STATE LEVEL OUR GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES WHICH IS THE MOST
COMPARABLE LEVEL. THIS IS EVEN
LOWER EVEN GREATER GAP BELOW OUR
PRIVATE SECTOR ATTORNEYS. OKAY
M. THE BURDEN OF ON AVERAGE
SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR IN
LOAN PAYMENT OBLIGATIONS WHAT
THOSE TOGETHER AND SOMEONE
LIVING IN LOS ANGELES IS ONLY
ABOUT TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS. LOVE
THE MINIMUM POVERTY LEVEL-
INCOME TO COVER BASIC EXPENSES
AFTER TAXES ALONG BATES YOU CAN
MAKE UP MORE THAN 10% INCREASE
IN THE DISPOSABLE INCOME OF
LEGAL AID LAWYERS. ARE TAX
EXEMPT BASIS SERVICE PROGRAM.
WELL I APPRECIATE THAT AND
ESPECIALLY THE- OF THE SERVICES
OF THESE LEGAL AID ATTORNEYS
BECAUSE FRANKLY WITHOUT THEM FAR
MORE PEOPLE WOULD BE AFFECTED
FAR MORE PEOPLE WOULD BE LIVING
IN CROWDED- CONDITIONS- MORE
PEOPLE WOULD END UP ON HOUSED I
MEAN THEY ARE. SAVING US FROM
HAVING TO SPEND MORE MONEY ON
ALL THESE OTHER KINDS OF
SERVICES BECAUSE IT WOULD OF
THOSE FAMILIES WOULD BE IN A
WORSE SITUATION SO ON THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THAT- SENATORS
COMMENTS QUESTIONS CENTER
NEWMAN- YOU'RE ON IT IT'S
PROBABLY A QUESTION FOR MR LEAP.
TO MY UNDERSTANDING IS WE WE'RE
WE'RE CONSIDERING- ANOTHER ONE
TIME ALLOCATION FOR THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET- AGAINST LAST YEAR'S
WINTER BUDGET SEEMS PRETTY CLEAR
FROM DISCUSSION HERE THAT THESE
ARE ONGOING NEEDS- IT'D THE
ANNOUNCES WE GOT ALSO NOTES
THERE WERE SOME HARPER FUNDS
THAT WERE- PROVIDING ON A ON A
THREE YEAR BASIS SO AS FOR
FURTHER QUESTIONS WHAT WHAT'S
LEFT. FOR THIS YEAR AND I SEEM
NEXT YEAR OF THE ORP OF FUNDS.
AND WHAT'S YOUR SENSE OF THE
ONGOING NEED- IN RESPONSE TO THE
FIRST QUESTION- SO FROM THE
FEDERAL OUR CURRENT CURRENT MY
WRISTS FISCAL RELIEF FUNDS- IT
WAS SPREAD ACROSS THREE YEARS.
SO THERE WAS ABOUT FORTY MILLION
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE THERE'S
TWENTY MILLION AND THEN IN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
THERE IS THE FINAL TWENTY
MILLION AND SO THEN THAT MONEY.
WILL BE GONE- AS AS AS- AS YOU
REFERENCED- SO IT'S HELPFUL
AGAIN SO IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE WHAT IS CURRENTLY.
IN AN ONGOING IN COMBINATION
FROM THE GENERAL FUND AS WELL AS
FROM CIVIL FILING FEES AND THEN
THAT TWENTY MILLION AND FEDERAL
DOLLARS THAT'S KIND OF WHAT'S
THERE. AND I DO APPRECIATE THAT
SO IT TOOK THAT IT SOUNDS AS IF
WERE- CERTAIN POSITION PLUS MAKE
ANOTHER ONE TIME ALLOCATION
AGAINST THE NEED THIS YEAR-
WHICH IS PROBABLY A GOOD THING
BUT YOU KNOW I DO GET CONCERNED.
CECI LOOKING OUT AT THE END OF
THE FISCAL ENVIRONMENT AND NOW
YEARS IN THE ABSENCE OF A
SURPLUS WE'RE GONNA MAKE SOME.
DIFFICULT CHOICES- SHOWED EACH
SHOULD THIS BE A LARGER ON GOING
ALLOCATION MOVING FORWARD OR IS
THERE A SENSE THAT THE NEED WILL
DECREASE AS THE EFFECTS OF A
PANDEMIC- START TO. SUBSIDE THE
LEGISLATURE HAS CERTAINLY BEEN-
EVALUATING IT AS PART OF YOUR
BROADER. GENERAL FUND
PRIORITIES- SO TO GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE- IN. BETWEEN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. THERE WAS AN
AUGMENTATION- THAT WAS INCLUDED
IN THE BUDGET TWENTY MILLION OF
THAT WAS ON GOING THIRTY MILLION
OF THAT. WAS ONE TIME- THAT'S
ACTUALLY NOT MS COPELAND
ACTUALLY MENTIONED THAT THAT'S
THIRTY MILLION. A ONE TIME AND
SO THE TWENTY MILLION ONGOING-
IS EFFECTIVE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AND WILL CONTINUE ON
THE LEGISLATURE IF IT IS A
PRIORITY CERTAINLY CAN ADD
ADDITIONAL PLANS WHETHER IT BE
ON A LIMITED TERM OR AN ON GOING
BASIS. AND JUST TO CLOSE THIS
OUT I GUESS FROM MS COPELAND
NINETY WHAT'S YOUR SENSES OF HOW
FAR WILL THAT. ONGOING
ALLOCATION MAKE US IN AN INSTANT
PERHAPS WE SHOULD BE
CONSIDERING. A LARGER ALLOCATION
WOULD BE FOUR HUNDRED ON ON
GOING BASIS. I MEAN FOR THE
LEGAL AID PROGRAMS IN YOUR
DISTRICT WOULD APPRECIATE
ONGOING ALLOCATION BUT I KNOW
THE REALITY OF THE PROJECT THAT
ONE TIME ALLOCATIONS ARE EASIER
TO MANAGE AND THAT- WHAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT LEGAL AID
ORGANIZATIONS TO BE ABLE TO
HIRE. INTO HIGHER STAFF
ATTORNEYS AND OTHER ADVOCATES
FOR PERMANENT POSITIONS RATHER
THAN TEMPORARY HIRES IS MULTI
YEAR FUNDING. ON GO ON GOING
FUNDING IS IDEAL OF COURSE THAT
MULTI YEAR ONE TIME FUNDING IS
ALSO COMPLETELY APPROPRIATE
BECAUSE ORGANIZATIONS CAN HIRE.
I'M IN THERE IS A WRINKLE THAT I
THINK MAY HAVE BEEN MENTIONED-
LAST YEAR WE DISCUSSED THIS AND
I THINK IT MAY ALSO BE MADE
ALISTAIR. IS I ALSO. COUNT HAVE
A SIGNIFICANT DROP. AVENUE AS
SOON AS THAT THAT KIND OF OUR
SKIN A CAT IN TWENTY TWENTY
BECAUSE INTEREST RATES DROP SO
MUCH RESIDE DECREASE OF I THINK
APPROXIMATELY APPROXIMATELY
TWENTY MILLION PER YEAR. IN
REVENUE AND THAT MONEY WENT
DIRECTLY TO LEGAL AID PROGRAMS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND AS
INTEREST RATES IMPROVE WE WILL
SEE THAT THAT AMOUNT SLOWLY
INCREASING AGAIN. IT'S JUST
GONNA BE QUITE A WHILE AND SO I
DON'T INTEREST RATES IMPROVE
ENOUGH THAT WE CAN GO BACK TO
PRIOR- REVENUE I BELIEVE WE HAD
ROUGHLY FIFTEEN MILLION IN
REVENUE. IN TWENTY NINETEEN AND. IT'S JUST REALLY TAKES THEM.
RICHARD YOU. THANK YOU- WE HAVE
A UP- FROM MISS MURRAY FROM THE
CALL LAW IN CONCUR COALITION I
KNOW YOU SCHEDULED TO- SPEAK ON
THE NEXT ISSUE BUT IF YOU WANT
TO JUMP IN HERE. JUST BRIEFLY
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AS YOU ARE
WELL AWARE I WITH SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN TWENTY FOUR- THERE IS
A- RESPONSE TO THE QUESTION
ABOUT THE TALE- THE ONGOING
EFFECTS OF THE PANDEMIC AND HOW
LONG- THESE THESE THESE NEEDS
WILL BE WITH US- WE HAVE AS JUST
ONE EXAMPLE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IN BACK RENT YET
NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE THIS.
IN IN THE STATE WE DON'T KNOW
HOW IT'S GOING TO PLAY OUT- BUT
THERE IS GOING TO BE A VAST NEED
FOR FOUR TOURNEY'S LEGAL AID
ATTORNEY TO HELP LOW INCOME
TENANTS WITH. THE COLLECTION OF
THOSE MONIES AND THAT WILL LAST
FOR YEARS. THANK YOU. I MEAN IT
DOES SEEM THAT THE INVESTMENT IN
HIRING AND RETAINING ESPECIALLY
RETAINING ATTORNEYS IS REALLY AT
THE HEART OF ALL OF THIS BECAUSE
WITHOUT THOSE ATTORNEYS. HOW CAN
YOU POSSIBLY ADDRESS ALL THE
ISSUES OF EVICTION THE ISSUES OF
CONSUMER DEBT. AND IF WE DON'T
ADDRESS THAT SO SOMEHOW I THINK
THAT SHOULD- PLAY A- BIG PART IN
FIGURING OUT THE- THE BUDGET.
SENATOR CORTEZ THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR IN IN IN IN- FROM- FROM MY
LOCAL EXPERIENCE IN IN TRYING TO
DEAL WITH ANY NUMBER OF ISSUES
INCLUDING IMMIGRATION ISSUES
WERE THE COUNTY. WANTED TO
EITHER PASS THROUGH STATE OR
FEDERAL MONEY OR JUST USES ON
GENERAL FUND. TO INCREASE- THIS
KIND OF CAPACITY. OF MORE THINGS
WE LEARNED WAS TO ESSENTIALLY
DISPROPORTIONATELY FOCUS THE
ASSISTANCE IN TWO. ATTORNEYS WHO
COULD FUNCTION IN A SUPERVISORY
CAPACITY LONG TERM BECAUSE THE
TURNOVER WE COULD NEVER SEEM TO
STOP THAT. IN THE CASES WOULD.
YOU KNOW MOVE ALONG- SOMETIMES
TWO OR THREE MONTHS AND THEN ALL
OF A SUDDEN- THE COUNSEL OF
RECORD WOULD BE GONE IN IT JUST
CREATED A VERY CHALLENGING
DISCUSS YOUR ATTENTION COMMENTED
VERY CHALLENGING SITUATION- YOU
KNOW FOR THOSE OF US WHO'VE BEEN
INVOLVED IN THE LOG NO TO. YOU
KNOW ALL OF A SUDDEN GO IN IN IN
IN START TRYING TO EXPLAIN TO
THE JUDGE OR MAGISTRATE THAT.
THE ATTORNEY OF RECORD IS NO
LONGER THERE IT'S DISRUPTIVE TO
THE- OBVIOUSLY TO THE CLIENT.
AND YOU KNOW JUST IS AN
EFFICIENT IN GENERAL SO. YOU
KNOW. I I'M FOR THIS- BUT I
CERTAINLY ENCOURAGE- THE
PROPONENTS TO CONTINUE TO LOOK
AT THAT KIND OF AN APPROACH
WHERE YOU KNOW IF YOU CAN'T
BRING EVERYBODY UP ALL THE TIME
YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF-
COMPETITIVENESS AND RETENTION.
AT LEAST BRING UP. A COHORT OF
MANAGEMENT LEADERSHIP FOLKS WHO
WHO CAN THEN STEP IN IF YOU LOSE
AN ATTORNEY THE ANSWER TO THE
QUESTION THAT BECAUSE WELL. THAT
SUPERVISORY ATTORNEY IS STAYING
CLOSE ENOUGH TO THE CASE TO BE
ABLE TO STEP IN AND KEEP THE
MOMENTUM GOING AND KEEP THE
REPRESENTATION EFFECTIVE SO JUST
MY THOUGHTS ARE. IT'S DEFINITELY
A BIG ISSUE IN ANY DOLLARS ARE
GOOD DOLLARS ALTHOUGH I AGREE
WITH. SENATOR NEWMAN THAT IF YOU
. MAYBE THESE PRISONERS DON'T
KNOW BUT WE'RE IN OLD OF.
ADVOCATING FOR ONE TIME ON. THIS
YEAR FOR ONGOING NEEDS AND I
THINK IT'S STARTING TO SCARE
SOME OF US AS TO WHAT HAPPENS.
WHEN THE BOTTOM FALLS OUT A
LITTLE BIT IN A COUPLE YEARS
AND- YOU KNOW CLIENTS IN A
SAFETY NET RECIPIENTS JUST. IN
ALL OF A SUDDEN ARE- YOU KNOW
NOT GETTING THE SERVICES THEY
NEED- YOU KNOW THROUGH NO FAULT
OF ANYONE OTHER THAN THIS THE
SYSTEM OF ONE TIME VERSUS
ONGOING MONEY. THANK YOU ANYWAY
THANK YOU FOR CALLING Q. I JUST
AND I REALLY. APPRECIATE MS
COPELAND MISTER LONDON AND
PARTICULARLY MYSTICAL PLAN WHEN
YOU I THINK IT WAS YOU WHO SAID-
THERE'S A- THERE ARE INDIVIDUAL
CASES AND IN THE PAST YOU HAD
INDIVIDUAL CASES BUT- SOMEHOW
YOU CAN REACH OUT TO A FAMILY
MEMBER TO A NEIGHBOR. THE
SOMEONE TO HELP BUT IF EVER IN
THE SAME BOAT EVERYBODY'S IN
TROUBLE EVERYBODY HAS DEBT WHERE
DO YOU GO AND WITHOUT AN
ATTORNEY YOU ABSOLUTELY WILL END
UP. ON HOUSE OR WORSE WHO KNOWS
WHAT ELSE COULD COULD BE
HAPPENING AND THEN WERE. CHASING
THAT PROBLEM. INSTEAD OF
THINKING IN ADVANCE SO IF
THERE'S ANYTHING ELSE THAT THAT
YOU WON AND WITH MYSTICAL
BLENDER MISTER LONDON. BEFORE WE
MOVE ON THE NEXT ISSUE. WELL I
HAD ONE OTHER EXAMPLE WHICH I'VE
I'VE DONE SHARED WITH WITH
THANKS SENATE STAFF. OF AN
ORGANIZATION THAT HELPS A WOMAN
WHO HAD MULTIPLE THREATS AGAINST
HER AND BECAUSE SHE WAS ACTUALLY
ON HOW SHE WAS JUDGMENT CREW.
AND SO SHE WAS UNABLE TO PAY
THOSE DEBTS. AND EVEN THOUGH SHE
OULD NEVER BE ABLE TO PAY THOSE
DEBTS THE FACT IT WAS ON HER
RECORD WAS A BARRIER TO HOUSING
SHE WAS TRYING TO GET IN IN
SECTION EIGHT HOUSING. IS A
WORKING WITH ILLEGALLY PROGRAM
THEY WORKED WITH THE LENDER AND
ACTUALLY. TO REMOVE THE DEBT FOR
HER RECORD AND SHE WAS ABLE TO
THE HOUSE SO YOU MAY THINK THAT
CONSUMER DEBT- JUST IMPACT YOUR
CREDIT RECORD BEING POSSIBILITY
TO GET WORK TO GET HOUSING. AND
WHEN YOU HAVE A LAWYER WHO CAN
HELP THEY CAN GET AT THE ROOT
ISSUE. HOPEFULLY SOLVE THAT ONE
PROBLEM THAT YOU CAN HAVE A
POSITIVE IMPACT ON THE REST OF
THEIR LIVES. THANK YOU FOR
LETTING ME GIVE ONE MORE EXAMPLE
THAT'S GREAT THANK YOU GREAT
EXAMPLE MISTER LONDON ANY FINAL
WORDS. JUSTICE CENTER MILLIONS
GOVERNMENT IS RIGHT AND-
CONTINUING FUNDING FOR
CONTINUING NEEDS IS A PROGRAM.
FOR RETAINING LAWYERS IT'S
ESPECIALLY NECESSARY NOW MULTI
YEAR CONTINUING. OUR FUNDING
BECAUSE- IN ORDER TO GET TO BE A
SUPERVISING ATTORNEY AS CENTER
CONTAINS A POINTED OUT. YOU NEED
TO HAVE A CAREER OF. FIVE OR SIX
YEARS. AT LEAST YEAH- WEARS A
SMART PEOPLE AND HELP THEM MAKE
DECISIONS ABOUT THEIR- PROSPECTS
ARE. HAVING IN MIND WHETHER.
THIS IS A ONE TIME- PROGRAM MORE
SO THAT THEY COUNT ON THE FUTURE
. GREAT THANK YOU BOTH VERY
MUCH- UP ALL THE WORK YOU DO A
THE SPECIAL SHOUT OUT TO ALL THE
LEGAL AID ATTORNEYS ARE OUT
THERE- HELP IN OUR COMMUNITY.
THANKYOU ABOUT WILL MOVE ON NOW
TO ISSUE TO THE COURT FILING
FEES- A WILL START WITH THE L.
A. L. IS THAT MISLI. YES THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- COMMITTEE STAFF
HAS ASKED US TO INTRODUCED THIS
ITEM. THE SENATE IS CONSIDERING
A PROPOSAL TO INCREASE THE
INCOME THRESHOLD FOR AUTOMATIC
FILING FEE WAIVERS IN CIVIL
CASES. THESE WAIVERS ARE
CURRENTLY GRANTED TO INDIVIDUALS
WITH INCOMES BELOW A HUNDRED AND
25% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
THRESHOLD. AND OR CERTAIN TYPES
OF GOVERNMENT ASSISTANCE. TO
REFLECT CALIFORNIA'S COST OF
LIVING THE PROPOSAL THE SENATE
IS CURRENTLY CONSIDERING WOULD
CONSIDER RAISING THE THRESHOLD
BASED ON CALIFORNIA INCOME AND
STAT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE'RE GOING TO HEAR NOW
FROM- MR MERMAN TED MERMAN FROM
THE CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME
CONSUMER COALITION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'D MISS OUT EVEN IF THE
MAKE- FROM- THE COMMUNITY LEGAL
SERVICES EAST PALO ALTO IS GONNA
GO FIRST I'LL BE. AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS. OKAY THANK YOU. NINETY THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS VANESSA NIET AND I'M A SENIOR
ATTORNEY COMMUNITY LEGAL
SERVICES IN EAST PALO ALTO WE
ARE PROUD TO CO SPONSOR SB THREE
FIVE FIVE WHICH IS AUTHORED BY
SENATOR BACKER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME CONSUMER
COALITION. IS THE PROBLEM. WANT
TO DEFEND THEMSELVES AGAINST
CIVIL LAWSUITS MUST PAY
SUBSTANTIAL FILING FEES IF THEY
DON'T QUALIFY FOR A FEE WAIVER.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIANS ONLY
QUALIFY FOR MEMBERS
AUTOMATICALLY IF THEY RECEIVE
FIRST CERTAIN BENEFITS. OR
SECOND THEIR INCOME IS UNDER A
125% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
GUIDELINES. IF A PERSON CAN'T
PAY THE FILING FEE. WHICH MAY
RUN TO HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS THEY
MAY NEVER RESPOND TO PERHAPS
AMERICA'S DEBT COLLECTION
LAWSUITS. THAT MEANS THE BANK
ACCOUNT MAYBE LEVY. THEIR WAGES
MAY BE GARNISHED EVEN IF THEY
DIDN'T ACTUALLY FOR THE MONEY
THAT THEY WERE SUED FOR. I
PROPOSED IS THREE FIVE FIVE AND
THE CORRESPONDING ENHANCEMENTS
IF WE CAN INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO RECEIVE A FILING FEE
WAIVER WE EXPAND ACCESS TO
JUSTICE. AND WE WERE JUST A
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO MAY NEVER
RESPOND TO LAWSUITS AND HAVE
THEIR ABILITY TO PAY FOR FOOD.
OR TO STAY HOUSE THREATENED AS A
RESULT. CALIFORNIA CAN MAKE
WORDS EXCESSIVE TO TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES YEAR.
OTHERWISE MIGHT NEVER HAVE THEIR
DAY IN COURT. TO MAKE THIS
HAPPEN WE'RE SPEAKING A BUDGET
ENHANCEMENTS THAT WILL PROVIDE
MORE TRUST IS TO MORE PEOPLE.
FOR MAKING SURE THAT OUR COURTS
ARE FUNDED TO COVER ANY
REDUCTION IN REVENUE RESULTING
FROM WORK HIGHLY REVERSE. TO
MAKE IT CLEAR AND LIKE TO SHARE
STORY. JOHN WILSON IS AN ELDERLY
RETIRED MAN WHO'S A VICTIM OF
IDENTITY FAST. THE IDENTITY
THIEF FRAUDULENTLY ENCOURAGED
THAT MR WILSON'S NAME. BUT MR
WILSON WAS SUED BY THE DEBT
COLLECTION AGENCY TO RECOVER THE
MONEY HE TRIED TO FILE A MOTION
TO STOP THE COLLECTION OF THE
DAY. BUT BEFORE HE COULD FILE
THE MOTION MISTER WILSON NEEDED
TO PAY A FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY
FIVE DOLLAR FILING FEE TO THE
COURT. THIS IS SOMETHING HE
COULD NOT DO. MISTER WILSON
LIVES IN A MONTHLY FIXED INCOME
OF TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM HIS
PENSION AND HAS RENT STABILIZED
HOUSING IN SAN FRANCISCO. BUT HE
DID NOT AUTOMATICALLY QUALIFY
FOR THE WAIVER. UNDER THE NEW
GUIDELINES WE PROPOSED TODAY
MISTER WILSON WHAT QUALIFY FOR
THE WAIVER AUTOMATICALLY. AND
THE CONSEQUENCES THAT HE
EXPERIENCE COULD HAVE BEEN
AVOIDED. PAYING OUT OF POCKET
FOR HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS IN
BOUNTIES CAN BE ALL BUT
IMPOSSIBLE WHEN A PERSON IS
SURVIVING PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK.
AS A RESULT MANY MERITLESS CASES
STILL AND IN A DEFAULT JUDGMENT
FOR THE PLAINTIFF. WITH
POTENTIALLY DIRE LONG TERM
FINANCIAL CONSEQUENCES. THE
FEDERAL RESERVE SHOWED STUDIES
CONSISTENTLY FOUND THAT ALMOST
HALF OF AMERICANS WOULD HAVE
TROUBLE PICKING EMERGENCY
EXPENSE. OF FOUR HUNDRED
DOLLARS. PER CONTACT THE INITIAL
FILING FEE AND AN UNLIMITED
CIVIL CASE IN CALIFORNIA IS NOW
FOR HER THIRTY FIVE DOLLARS.
THIS BUDGET ENHANCEMENT WILL
MODERNIZE THE INCOMES
INTERPERSONAL FILING FEE WAIVERS
REDUCE JUDICIAL TIME AND
RESOURCES AND FUND THE COURTS.
ARE ACCESS TO JUSTICE FOR LOGAN. CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR MERMAN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS THAT HAD NORMAN DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME
CONSUMER COALITION I JUST SAY I
HAVE MY COLLEAGUE MISS NIGHT
BECAUSE THAT POIGNANTLY I THINK
LAID OUT THE NEED FOR THIS
BUDGET ITEM- WE DO NOT WANT AS A
STATE TO BE DEPRIVING OUR LOW
INCOME RESIDENTS OF THEIR
ABILITY TO FIGHT UNJUST DEBT
COLLECTION OR TO KEEP THEIR
HOMES. IN THE FACE OF A
FORECLOSURE OR EVICTION LAWSUITS
SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY CAN'T AFFORD
THE FILING FEES NEEDED TO
RESPOND- I WANT TO ADD THAT WE
APPRECIATED THE INPUT F THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL AND WE ARE
COMMITTED TO PUTTING IN PLACE A
BUDGETARY REGIME THIS YEAR THAT
COVERS ANY POTENTIAL LOSS OF
REVENUE FROM THE INCREASE IN FEE
WAIVERS. I'M OF COURSE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE THANK YOU.
OKAY WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
QUESTIONS- I HAVE ONE- WHAT IS
THE PROCESS FOR APPLYING FOR A
FEE WAIVER IF YOU DON'T MEET THE
AUTOMATIC. REQUIREMENT IS THERE
PROCESS FOR THAT. YES IF YOU
DON'T QUALIFY FOR THE AUTOMATIC
FEE WAIVER YOU CAN FILL OUT F.
W. O. ONE. AND YOU CAN PRESENT
INFORMATION ABOUT YOUR INCOME
YOUR RENT YOUR MONTHLY GROCERY
PAYMENTS MEDICAL CAR INSURANCE
ETCETERA TO SHOW HOW MUCH YOU
HAVE LEFT OVER. AND YOUR
INABILITY TO PAY HOWEVER OUR
CLIENTS CONSISTENTLY STATE THAT
THIS IS HUMILIATING FOR THEM TO
HAVE TO PROVE INSURGENCY. AND
MANY OF THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE TO
USE THAT FORM DO I QUALIFY BUT
IT DOES TAKE JUDICIAL TIME AND
RESOURCES TO ENSURE TO KEEP
THOSE BEING REVERSED WHEN THEY
COULD BE AUTOMATICALLY GRANTED.
THANK YOU. OF MEMBERS SENATE
CRITICIZING. YOUR JUSTICE- ONE
OF A TECHNICAL QUESTION HERE THE
INDEXING TO THE FEDERAL POVERTY
THRESHOLD IS WITH. IS THERE BEEN
ANY DISCUSSION TO MAKE THAT THE
ADJUSTED OF. THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL. FOR EXAMPLE I'M LOOKING
IN THE- OUR PACKET NOTES WHICH
INDICATED ON PAGE FOUR- FIFTY
FIVE THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED FOR
FAMILY OF FOUR BEING. THE
FEDERAL PARTY TOLD WHICH IS
ACTUALLY. ADJUSTED TO WELL OVER
SIXTY THOUSAND DOLLARS AS I
RECALL IN IN MY COUNTY SOME I'M
JUST WONDERING IF THAT'S- BEEN
CONSIDERED AS PART OF THE
FRAMEWORK. TONY BY COUNTY
INDEXING I DON'T KNOW. WHO WOULD
I WOULD LIKE TO TOSS A QUESTION
TOO I'M SORRY. FOR WHO WOULD
LIKE TO ANSWER THAT. I AM HAPPY
TO START WE ARE CONSIDERED
COUNTY BY COUNTY INDEXING FOR
AREA MEDIAN INCOMES. ARE
PROVISIONAL COUNCIL RIGHTLY
POINTED OUT THAT THIS IS A STATE
WIDE FORM. SO THEY REQUESTED A
STANDARD FOR THE WHOLE STATE-
PLEASE LET ME KNOW IF THAT
ANSWERS THE QUESTION OF THERE'S
ANYTHING THAT I CAN FURTHER
CLARIFY- APPRECIATE THE ANSWER
IT'S GREAT THAT IT'S BEEN
DISCUSSED- I WOULD. PUSH BACK A
LITTLE BIT ON. JUST BECAUSE IT'S
STATE DOLLARS THAT IT NEEDS TO
BE- A STATEWIDE INDEX YOU KNOW-
LET'S SEE WHAT INDEX VERSUS ONE
THAT'S THAT'S TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT
IT JUST MEANS- COUNTY BY COUNTY
IT IS THE STATE IS SO DIVERSE I
THINK IN A PERFECT WORLD. WE
WOULD HAVE IN AND ANY NUMBER OF
ISSUES- YOU KNOW SORT OF EVEN
ECONOMIC CONDITIONS UP AND DOWN
THE STATE BUT- IT IS WELL KNOWN
THE COST OF LIVING IN CERTAIN
PLACES- SILICON VALLEY A LOT OF.
A LOT OF COASTAL CITIES- I THINK
CERTAIN PARTS OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. ARE ARE OFF THE MAP
COMPARED TO- ARE OFF THE CHARTS
COMPARED TO SOMEPLACE LIKE- YOU
KNOW CENTRAL VALLEY COUNTY OR
EVEN A CAT COUNTY AND IN IN THE
NORTHEAST FOR EXAMPLE SO IT JUST
IT JUST. I JUST WORRY THAT FOLKS
THEY WERE TRYING TO SERVE GET
SORT OF CAUGHT- YOU KNOW IN
BETWEEN- IT AND IT IT ADDED THEY
JUST PUSH BACK IS IT JUST
DOESN'T SEEM THAT HARD TO JUST
APPLY. YOU KNOW THE TYPICAL
INDEXES THAT ARE OUT THERE TO
MAKE THE ADJUSTMENT. MAYBEMISLI
IF YOU HAVE SOME THOUGHTS ON
THAT ESPECIALLY BECAUSE IT'S
BEEN DISCUSSED. IT'S CERTAINLY
WE CAN WE CAN FOLLOW UP WITH
STAFF- OF THE COMMITTEE UT ALSO
PERSONAL STAFF- IF YOU ARE
PARTICULARLY INTERESTED ON THIS
ISSUE AND SEE WHAT INFORMATION.
WE CAN HELP- PROVIDE OR IF
THEY'RE CONVERSATIONS THAT NEED
TO TAKE PLACE AND BE HAPPY TO
HELP OUT WITH THAT. OKAY WILL BE
FOLLOW UP THEN WITH CENTER
CORTESE. THANK YOU. CENTER
NEWMAN NOW YES RIGHT I'VE GOT A
I GUESS A MORE GENERALIZED.
QUESTION OBSERVATION SO. ONE OF
THE STATURE IN THE IN THE
ANALYSIS FOR THE EARLIER ITEM
NOTES THAT- 60% OF LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS ARE HAVE BEEN
SUBJECT TO HARASSMENT FROM
CREDITORS AND 50% OFF ON HARM.
THE AS OF THE RESULT OF SCAMS IN
WHICH IS I MEAN WE THINK ABOUT
HEALTH WHICH OF THOSE HUGE
NUMBERS. AND SO THERE'S A
THERE'S A BROADER CHALLENGE MADE
YOU KNOW SO ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
YOURS CAN ONLY HELP THOSE WHO
COME TO YOU. HOW DO WE DO A
BETTER JOB. MAKING THIS BIG
CONSUMERS LOW INCOME CONSUMERS
RECEIVE AWARE OF THESE
RESOURCES. AND YOU KNOW TO
CENTER CRETACEOUS POINT ARE YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGES AND FACING DEBT IS
JUST BEING OVERWHELMED BY DEBT
AND ONE OF THE REASONS WHY A LOT
OF THESE GO DEFAULT JUDGMENTS IS
PEOPLE JUST. ARE SIMPLY
OVERWHELMED BY LIFE BY DAD- AND
THAT'S WHY FOR INSTANCE. NOTICES
FROM THE IRS DON'T GET OPEN. AND
I'M COMPLETELY SYMPATHETIC TO
THAT SO THERE'S THIS BROADER
QUESTION ABOUT WHAT IS TO TAKE
WHAT WE NEED REVISED TO EDUCATE
CALIFORNIANS AS. TO KNOW THEIR
RIGHTS WITH THESE RESOURCES. I
WOULD ABOVE AND BEYOND WHAT WE
MIGHT PROVIDE TODAY BY WAY OF.
YOU KNOW THROUGH INCREASING THE
THRESHOLD HAS HAD LEFT HERE FROM
OKAY AND OBVIOUSLY THIS IS MR
MERMAN YEAH ANY THOUGHTS. YES
SENATOR THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT- WHAT YOU SAY- TRACKS THE
EXPERIENCES OF CLICKS MEMBERS.
MEET MS COPELAND- MAY ACTUALLY
HAVE SOMETHING TO SAY I THINK
ABOUT STATEWIDE EFFORTS AT
EDUCATION- THERE ARE OTHER BILLS
POLICY BILLS THAT ARE THAT ARE
PENDING THIS YEAR THAT SEEK TO
ADDRESS. SOME OF THE FRAUD- AND
SENT TO PREVENT- SOME O THE
FRAUD THAT THAT YOU'VE MENTIONED
BEFORE I'VE I'VE I WILL I'LL
REPRESENT THAT WE LOOK FORWARD
TO- TO- MAYBE OPENING A
CONVERSATION YOUR OFFICE ABOUT
THIS. WE APPRECIATE THAT THANK I
THINK IT'S YOU KNOW CERTAINLY WE
SHOULD DO THESE THINGS. BUT
INFORMING CALIFORNIANS YOU KNOW
AS TO THEIR RIGHTS AND RESOURCES
THIS IS A BIG DEAL- THE PANDEMIC
MADE IT VERY CLEAR THE MOVIE FOR
WE SHOULD LEARN FROM THAT THANK
THANK YOU. WELL I KNOW SOMEONE
WHO HAS A BILL THAT'S- MOVING UP
TO HAVE RENT DEBT. COLLECTED OR
TREATED AS CONSUMER DEBTS IT HAS
ALL OF THE PROTECTIONS AGAINST
HARASSMENT JUST ONE OF THE
ISSUES THAT YOU RAISED. SO ALL
HAVE THAT SENATOR PASS IT ON TO
YOU I'D LIKE TO TALK TO THAT
CENTER SO. AT THANK YOU MANAGER.
OKAY OF MORE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ANY FINAL WORDS MR
MERMAN OR MISS. A NIGHT LAKE. IF
I MAY RESPOND TO SENATOR CORTEZ
HE'S CONTENT I UNDERSTAND THE
CONCERN ABOUT HAVING A STATE
WIDE RECOUNTING WHY. INDEX
HOWEVER I WOULD LIKE TO NOTE
THAT THE MORE POPULATED COUNTIES
TO ACCOUNT FOR MORE REVENUE FOR
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL AND FOR THE
COURTS. AND THEY HAVE HIGHER
LEVELS OF POVERTY THEY HAVE
HIGHER POPULATIONS MORE PEOPLE
WILL SEEK THE COURTS AND HAVE
THEIR DAY IN COURT IN THOSE
COUNTIES. SO WE NEED TO REFLECT
THE INCOME SKINNER THAT REFLECTS
THE INCOME OF CALIFORNIA THE
HIGH COST OF LIVING. WE DO HAVE
PROPOSALS UNDER THE FEDERAL
POVERTY GUIDELINES. BUT WE
BELIEVE THAT USING THE STATE
MEDIAN INCOME AS A STANDARD IS
MORE REFLECTIVE OF THE
COMMUNITIES AND THE COST OF
LIVING HERE WHICH IS WHY I
RESPECTFULLY. REQUESTING THE
ENHANCEMENT BACK LEVEL BECAUSE
THAT WOULD ACCOUNT FOR. THE HIGH
COST OF LIVING AND GET MORE OF
THE POPULATION THAT WE BELIEVE
WILL ACCESS THE COURTS. SO I
HOPE THAT ADDRESSES YOUR
CONCERNS. THANK YOU TO THE TO
THE CHAIR OF IN A MISS. IN A
MORE HAPPY TO YOU KNOW. TALK
SOME MORE- OFFICE TO OFFICE ON
THIS BUT- YOU KNOW YOU. ALL HAVE
BEEN USING A LOT OF EXAMPLES IN
MY COUNTY IT'S MY RECOLLECTION
AND I COULD BE OFF A LITTLE BIT
BUT I'VE- ACTUALLY HAD EMPLOYEES
IN THIS CATEGORY UNFORTUNATELY
EVEN. EVEN AT COUNTY A PAYROLL
LEVELS- THAT- A SINGLE MOTHER OF
TWO. IN OUR COUNTY WOULD BE
CONSIDERED UNDER THE FEDERALLY
JUST POVERTY LEVEL- IN THE MID
SIXTY THOUSAND RANGE REMEMBER
THE NUMBER SIXTY THREE OR SIXTY
SEVEN. SO WHAT I'M GETTING AT
HERE IS THAT TAT PERSON IS OF
FALLS INTO- THE COURT FEE
WAIVERS. FRAMEWORK WELL WHY
WOULDN'T SHE QUALIFY IN MY
COUNTY FOR THE FEE WAIVER IF
THAT'S THE WAY THIS WORKS IN IN
MAYBE THAT'S NOT THE WAY IT
WORKS. THAT'S IN IN I'M NOT. AT
I GET IT THAT IN YOU KNOW FOR
FIVE COUNTIES OVER OR YOU'VE
DONE THE SAN BENITO OR SOMEWHERE
ELSE MAYBE IT'S FIFTY FIVE. FOR
THE SAME PERSON. BUT YOU JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT.THE
SINGLE MOTHER OF TWO IN MY
COUNTY DOESN'T GET LEFT OUT OF
WHAT. THE SINGLE MOTHER OF TWO
IN SAN BENITO COUNTY WHICH WOULD
GET JUST BECAUSE WE'VE GOT. YOU
KNOW SORT OF THIS- SPACES- YOU
KNOW THIS PLAN LINE- THIS FLAT
LINE INDEXING THE UP AND THE
STATE- S. WHERE THAT POVERTY
LEVEL NUMBER IS. SO I DON'T KNOW
IF I'M CLARIFY MY CONCERN AT
ALL- BUT AGAIN IF I AM. OUT SIDE
THE CHALK LINES YOU'RE WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT. YOU KNOW
WE DON'T NEED TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION BELIEVER WE HAVE A
LONG COMMITTEE MEETING TODAY AND
I'M MORE THAN HAPPY TO DISCUSS
IT FURTHER. OFFLINE OKAY WILL
ENCOURAGE OUR OWN. THE CENTERS
AND- MISLI TO FOLLOW UP WITH-
CENTER CORTESE. OKAY THANK YOU
ALL VERY MUCH I REALLY
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU DO EVERY DAY
AND- FOR YOUR INSIGHT. WE WANT
TO ISSUE THREE WHICH IS COURT
APPOINTED SPECIAL ADVOCATES.
START WITH THE L. A. O. MISLI.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- COMMITTEE
STAFF HAS ALSO ASKED US TO
INTRODUCED THIS ITEM AND SO THE
SENATE IS CONSIDERING A PROPOSAL
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
THE CASA ASSOCIATION TO EXPAND
TO SERVICES PROVIDED IN THE
STATE. CASA PROGRAMS ARE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS THAT
PROVIDE TRAINED VOLUNTEERS
APPOINTED BY A JUVENILE COURT
JUDGE TO ESTABLISH AN ONGOING
RELATIONSHIP WITH CHILDREN IN
FOSTER CARE IN ORDER TO SUPPORT
AND ADVOCATE FOR THEM SUCH AS
ACCOMPANYING THEM TO COURT
HEARINGS- X. CENTER AT. THE
STATE- CURRENTLY PROVIDES ABOUT
TWO POINT FIVE SEVEN MILLION AND
I'M GOING GENERAL FUND SUPPORT
FOR THE COSTA PROGRAM IT WAS
LAST INCREASED TO THIS AMOUNT IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
STATE FUNDING USED TO SUPPORT.
CASA COSTS SUCH AS THE
SUPERVISORS THAT THAT- MONITOR
THE VOLUNTEERS AS WELL AS
RECRUITING AND TRAINING
ACTIVITIES. OUR UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THE STATE PROVIDED FUNDING
REPRESENTS SLIGHTLY MORE THAN
10% OF TOTAL COSTS OPERATIONS-
ON FOSTER FUNDING- AND THE STATE
MONEY IS USED TO DRAW DOWN MONEY
FROM VARIOUS OTHER SOURCES SUCH
AS CORPORATE AND INDIVIDUAL
DONORS X. SENTARA. THANK YOUNG.
GREAT THANK YOU MISLI OUT WE
MOVE ON TO SHARON LAWRENCE FROM
CALIFORNIA CASA MISS LAWRENCE.
WARNING CHAIR DURAZO AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS SHARON LAWRENCE AND I
AM HONORED TO BE THE CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA COURT APPOINTED
SPECIAL ADVOCATE ASSOCIATION.
THE TRUEST WORDS I'VE EVER HEARD
A FORMER FOSTER YOUTH SAY QUOTE
IT SHOULDN'T HURT TO BE A KID I
WONDER HOW DIFFERENT MY LIFE
WOULD HAVE BEEN HAVE THERE BEEN
SOMEONE IN MY CHILDHOOD WHO IS
ABLE TO REALLY HEAR ME BE WITH
ME PROTECT ME. END QUOTE IN
TWENTY TWENTY CALIFORNIA HAD A
DUBIOUS DISTINCTION WE LED THE
NATION WITH THE MOST YOUTH AND
CHILDREN IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY
THOUSAND CHILDREN WHO WERE
REMOVED FROM THEIR HOMES AND
THEIR FAMILIES BECAUSE OF ABUSE
AND NEGLECT AND PLACED INTO THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM. THESE WARDS
OF THE STATE OUR CHILDREN ARE
LITTLE BOYS AND LITTLE GIRLS
TEENAGERS AND YOU WHO HAVE DONE
NOTHING WRONG. BUT THEY'VE BEEN
PLACED INTO A COMPLEX COURT AND
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM WHERE THEIR
INDIVIDUAL VOICES MAY NOT BE
HEARD. LAST YEAR TEN THOUSAND
COURT APPOINTED SPECIAL
ADVOCATES OR CASAS HOPE THAT
THIRTEEN THOUSAND CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN. AFTER BEING RECRUITED
AND TRAINED BY PROFESSIONAL
STAFF AND R. FORTY FOUR LOCAL
PROGRAMS CLASSES ARE ASSIGNED TO
FOSTER CHILDREN WORKING ONE ON
ONE THEY GET TO KNOW THE CHILD
LEARN ABOUT THEIR DREAMS GET
ACQUAINTED WITH THEIR FAMILIES
AND CAREGIVERS. WE VIEW OFFICIAL
RECORDS INTERVIEW THE CHILD
SOCIAL WORKERS ATTORNEYS DOCTORS
AND TEACHERS. ULTIMATELY THE
CLASSES PROVIDE INPUT AND
RECOMMENDATIONS TO DEPENDENCY
COURT JUDGES ABOUT THE CHILD'S
BEST INTEREST. BUT EVEN MORE
IMPORTANTLY ACOSTA IS BY THE
SIDE OF A CHILD DURING A PRETTY
AWFUL TIME IN THEIR LIFE
PROVIDING HOPE. IN CALIFORNIA WE
SERVE FAR TOO FEW OF THESE
CHILDREN ONLY 16% OF THE
CHILDREN IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM HAVE ACOSTA. AT A COST OF
FORTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS MOST
OF WHICH COMES FROM PRIVATE
PHILANTHROPY. WHICH IS WHY I AM
HERE TODAY TO ASK YOU TO INVEST
IN OUR NETWORK OF LOCAL CASA
PROGRAMS ALL OVER THE STATE SO
WE CAN BUILD CAPACITY AND SERVE
MORE CHILDREN. OUR VISION IS
THAT WE WANT TO SERVE 60% OF THE
CHILDREN IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM BUT TO DO THAT WE NEED
SPECIFICALLY STATE FUNDING OF
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION TO BE
EXPENDED OVER THREE YEARS TO
PROVIDE THE INFRASTRUCTURE. AND
CAPACITY NEEDED TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF CHILDREN SERVED BY
CLASSES. THE MAJORITY OF THESE
FUNDS WOULD GO TO THE LOCAL CASA
PROGRAMS IN FIFTY ONE COUNTIES
WHERE 99% OF THE FOSTER CHILDREN
RESIDE. SIXTY MILLION FOUR COULD
PASS SEE THE BUILDING IN
INCREASING STAFF. AND FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR STATEWIDE
SERVICES SUCH AS RECRUITMENT
CAMPAIGNS CURRICULUM DEVELOPMENT
AND SYSTEM EFFICIENCIES. THIS
INVESTMENT IN OUR STATE COSTA
NETWORK WILL JUMPSTART OUR
VISION AND PROVIDE LIFE ALTERING
ASSISTANCE TO MORE ABUSED AND
NEGLECTED CHILDREN. IT SHOULDN'T
HURT TO BE A KID THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS
LAWRENCE OF I HAVE A UGH A
QUESTION FOR YOU COULD YOU UP.
TELL US A LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW
YOU RECRUIT- THE ADVOCATES AND
WHAT KIND OF TRAINING YOU DO
AND- SO WE CAN HAVE AN IDEA
FROM. WHO THEY ARE. WHAT SO COST
IS A RECRUITED A NUMBER OF WAYS
BY DIFFERENT PROGRAMS GENERALLY
THERE ARE PUBLIC SERVICE
ANNOUNCEMENTS AND THERE ARE
MARKETING CAMPAIGNS AT CROSSES
pEVENTS WHERE WE CAN RECRUIT MORE
CLASSES THAT WILL DO WE AND QUAN
A SKYPE MEETING SERVICE
ORGANIZATIONS. ACOSTA PROGRAMS
ALSO RECRUIT FROM LOCAL
CHURCHES- WHEN STORIES IN
NEWSPAPERS AND CALIFORNIA CUTS
THAT DOES LEAD STATEWIDE
MARKETING AND PUBLIC TV AND
RADIO ADS SO WE DO TRY TO
RECRUIT OUR CLASSES FROM A
VARIETY OF SOURCES THE NUMBER
ONE BEST WAY TO BE COULD ACOSTA
IS TO HAVE A CASA BRING A FRIEND
OR COLLEAGUE INTO THE PROGRAM. I
COST OUR VOLUNTEERS TO THEIR
PEOPE MEN AND WOMEN FROM MY
COMMUNITY THEY MUST BE OVER THE
AGE OF TWENTY ONE AND THEN MUST
UNDERGO THIRTY FIVE HOURS OF
TRAINING AS A VOLUNTEER. AT THE
TOP IS INCLUDES SUCH THINGS AS
THE LAWS- INVOLVING A CHILD
WELFARE AND THE RESPONSIBILITIES
OF SOCIAL WORKERS I DIVERSITY
EQUITY INCLUSION- HOW TO WORK
WITH FAMILIES- BUILDING
RELATIONSHIPS AND- WHAT SERVICES
ARE OUT THERE FOR FOSTER YOUTH
INCLUDING EDUCATIONAL. IN
ADDITION TO THE THIRTY FIVE
HOURS OF INITIAL TRAINING AND
THE TOPICS ARE MANDATED. BY THE
STATE WILL SUPPORT FOR OUR SAYS
THEY MUST ALSO TAKE TWELVE HOURS
OF CONTINUING EDUCATION A YEAR
TO KEEP UP TO DATE ON ALL SORTS. OF NEW PRACTICES AND POLICIES.
WELL GOOD CONGRADULATIONS ON ALL
OF THAT AND- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BECAUSE- THAT- THAT KIND OF
COMMITMENT- IT'S PRETTY AMAZING
AND VERY MUCH APPRECIATED
CENTER NEWMAN YOUNG- I'M A PROUD
FORMER CONCERT SO IT'S MISS
LAWRENCE NICE TO SEE- MOST OF
THE PROUD AUTHOR OF THE
RESOLUTION THIS MONTH TO MAKE
MAY- COSTS A MONTH THAT
CALIFORNIA- AND I TELL YOU HOW I
WAS RECRUITED BY MY WIFE SHE
DRAGGED ME TO INFORMATION HERE.
AND YOU KNOW DID WE ONCE YOU
UNDERSTAND THE NEED- YOU KNOW
IT'S HARD TO SAY NOBODY BUT YOU
KNOW IT IS THERE IS THAT
CHALLENGE AS WITH ANYTHING ABOUT
YOU KNOW HOW TO CONVEY- THE
NEIGHBOR ALSO FIND THE RIGHT
PEOPLE AND I THINK THERE WAS A
THERE WAS EXAMPLE DID SEVERAL
YEARS AGO WITH ONE OF THE SMART
THINGS OF THE COSTA DONE OUR
AREA WAS THEY WERE RUNNING OF
VIDEO FOR PROSPECTIVE JURORS- IN
IN YOU KNOW SHE SAID ABOUT
RICHARD WILL- AND AS THEY WERE
ABOUT THE FORCED TO DISCONTINUE
IT BECAUSE IT WAS BE WITH. IT
WOULD LOSE THE JURY POOL SHOW
THAT THERE'S A BIG CHALLENGE IN
FINDING THE RIGHT KINDS OF FOLKS
TO SERVICE CROSSES- I FOR MY
PART I AM BETTER AND I THINK
SMARTER FOR BEING ACOSTA DID
THERE'S A SLICE OF LIFE IN ANY
ANY PLACE RESPECT TO ORANGE
COUNTY IF YOU SEE IF YOU HAVE
SPENT A DAY IN JVENILE COURT-
ALONGSIDE A KID WHOSE USER.
TRYING TO NAVIGATE THAT SYSTEM
WITH WITHOUT MUCH BY WAY
RESOURCES YEAH IT IS WRENCHING-
AND YOU KNOW THE AND SO YOU KNOW
WHO DOES SPEAK FOR THE CHILD SO
WE NEED MORE CLASSES I'D I'M
GLAD TO SUPPORT THIS IN ANY WAY
THAT I CAN- I AM CONCERNED
HOWEVER ABOUT YOU KNOW THE
BROADER CHALLENGES OF MARKETING
RIGHT EIGHT HOW DO WE REACH A
PERSPECTIVE KOSS'S- ADVOCATES.
YOU KNOW GLAD TO RESOURCE ANYWAY
THAT I CAN'T. BUT THIS IS NOT.
IN WHEN YOU LOOK AT SORT OF A
LARGE SURPLUS. I THINK YOU MAKE
ALL THAT THE BRIDGE. ON THE-
WOULD BE. HUGE MORE IN. TO
MISSILE POINT THE- IS WHAT IS-
AND KIDS ARE FULLY DESERVE. OF
ITS SUPPORT AS THEY POSSIBLY
HAVE. AS THEY MAKE THEIR WAY TO
ADULTHOOD BUT SERVED YOU KNOW
THANK YOU THE TESTIMONY TO BE
GLAD TO HELP IN ANYWAY THAT I
CAN. THANK YOU SAID. THE NEWMAN
FOR SPONSORING AT CONCEPT RISHI
ASIAN WE REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
. OKAY THE NEW KRITISIERT
INFIELD OKAY OF. WE THINK IT TO
SENATOR NEWMAN'S- ISSUE THAT HE
HAS RAISED ABOUT THE
RECRUITMENT- YOU MENTIONED THE
VARIOUS WAYS- IS THERE A-
SHORTAGE OF COSTS OF. POTENTIAL
CAUSES OF HOW WOULD YOU ADDRESS
THAT IF THERE IS AND IF WITH
THIS- INCREASE- YOU'RE
EXPECTING- OF COURSE SEVERAL
THOUSAND MORE OF VOLUNTEERS A
MORE ADVOCATES HOW WOULD YOU
FEEL THAT NEED AS FAR AS
RECRUITMENT. RECRUITMENT IS A
HUGE ISSUE FOR US BECAUE NOT
MANY PEOPLE KNOW ABOUT THE COURT
APPOINTED SPECIAL ADVOCATE
PROGRAM AT ONCE PEOPLE LEARN
ABOUT IT THEY GET VERY EXCITED
BUT ONE OF THE BARRIERS THAT WE
HAVE IS THAT WE'RE WORKING WITH
CHILDREN IN A CONFIDENTIAL
CLOSED COURT SYSTEM SO WE CAN'T
ACTUALLY SHOW THE CHILDREN OR
TELL THOSE STORIES WHEN USING
THEIR TRUE NAMES. SO IT'S A
SYSTEM THAT NOT A LOT OF PEOPLE
KNOW ABOUT- RECENTLY WE DID A
PSA PUBLIC SERVICE ANNOUNCEMENT
WITH A FORMER SURGEON GENERAL DR
NADINE BURKE HARRIS I AND WE I
PLAYED THAT ALL OVER CALIFORNIAN
IT REALLY DID BRING IN
VOLUNTEERS SO OUR STRATEGY
REALLY IS TO. INCREASE THE
VISIBILITY OF THE LOCAL CASA
PROGRAMS DO STATEWIDE MARKETING
BOTH IN PRINT RADIO AND TV SO
THAT WE CAN REALLY RAISE OUR
VISIBILITY AND WE WERE ABLE TO
DO IT IN SAN DIEGO AT SAN
DIEGO'S PROGRAM IS NOW SERVING
THE MAJORITY THEIR CHILDREN. BUT
IT JUST TAKES HARD WORK AND IT
DOES TAKE AN INVESTMENT IN
MARKETING WHICH IS WHERE THE
STATE WOULD PUT- MANY MORE
DOLLARS WE'VE NEVER HAD THE
RESOURCES TO DO A STATEWIDE
CAMPAIGN OF THE NATURE THAT
WE'RE LOOKING FOR AND YES AND IT
SENATOR RAND THERE IS A SHORTAGE
OF PROCESS. ON BECAUSE DON'T I
THINK THE PUBLIC DOESN'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY CAN DO TO
HELP FAMILIES AND SO IT WOULD BE
A HUGE MEDIA BLITZ OVER THE NEXT
SEVERAL YEARS I WITH A TARGETED
STRATEGY BE. TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE HELPING MORE CHILDREN AND
WE THINK WE CAN DO IT WITH THE
RIGHT INVESTMENT. RIGHT OKAY IF
NO OTHER CAR THANK YOU MISS
LAWRENCE APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK
THAT YOU DO AND- A BIG
APPRECIATION TO THE PROCESS THAT
ARE OUT THERE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
OKAY BUT WE MOVE ON NOW TO ISSUE
FOR. A RELINQUISHMENT
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM AND WE WILL
HAVE ON THE L. A. OLE MISS LEE
MAKE A PRESENTATION. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MADAM CHAIR- SISENSE I
JUST ASK THAT WE INTRODUCED THIS
PROPOSAL BUT ALSO- KIND OF
PROVIDE SOME CONTEXT WHICH IS
REFLECTED IN YOUR AGENDA RELATED
TO ANALYSIS THAT WE DID AS PART.
OF OUR WORK ANALYZING THE
GOVERNOR'S PUBLIC SAFETY
PACKAGE- IF YOU RECALL THERE WAS
A PROPOSAL AND THAT WAS PART OF
THAT BARGAIN BUY BACK PROGRAM SO
THE SENATE IS CURRENTLY
CONSIDERING A PROPOSAL RELATED
TO FIREARM RELINQUISHMENT- WHEN
WE WERE DOING OUR WORK WE
PRESENTED- INFORMATION RELATED
TO- A FIRE ARM. KIND OF DATA.
AND SO THAT IS SOME OF THAT
INFORMATION IS NOTED IN YOUR
AGENDA AND SPECIFICALLY STATE
THAT INDICATED THAT THERE HAS
BEEN A GROWTH. IN HOMICIDE
FIREARM DEATHS AS WELL AS AN
INCREASE IN THE SHARE OF
HOMICIDES AGGRAVATED ASSAULTS
AND ROBBERIES THAT HAVE INVOLVED
FIREARMS. ADDITIONALLY AS OF
JANUARY FIRST OF THIS YEAR THERE
WERE ABOUT TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS ON THE
STATE'S ARMED AND PROHIBITED
PERSONS LAST. THESE ARE
INDIVIDUALS WHO SUBSEQUENTLY
BECOME PROHIBITED FROM
POSSESSING FIREARMS AND
AMMUNITION THAT THEY HAD
PURCHASED LEGALLY BEFORE.
BECAUSE THEY WERE CONVICTED OF
FELONIES AND SOME MISDEMEANOR.
FOUND BY A COURT TO BE A DANGER
TO THEMSELVES OR OTHERS DUE TO
MENTAL ILLNESS OR HAVE A
RESTRAINING ORDER AGAINST THEM.
AS PART OF OUR ANALYSIS WE DID
HIGHLIGHT TWO OPTIONS FOR
LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION IF THE
LEGISLATURE WAS INTERESTED IN-
KIND OF TARGETING FIREARM
RELATED I'M PUBLIC SAFETY CALLS
AND BOTH OF THOSE ARE REFLECTED
IN YOUR AGENDA. AND SO ONE- WAS
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
DOJ'S GUN VIOLENCE REDUCTION
PROGRAM FOR COMPETITIVE GRANTS
TO FURTHER REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
ARMED AND PROHIBITED PERSONS ON
THE STATE LAST. AND ALSO TO-
EXPAND TO POTENTIALLY EXPAND THE
LANGUAGE THAT OTHER ONE FORSMAN
AGENCIES BEYOND TO THE SHERIFF'S
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR THOSE
GRANTS. THE OTHER OPTION THAT WE
PROVIDED WAS RELATED TO REMOVING
FIREARMS FROM INDIVIDUALS WHEN
THEY BECOME PROHIBITED AND THIS
IS SORT OF IN LINE WITH WHAT THE
SENATE IS CONSIDERING AS PART OF
THIS- ISSUE. THIS IS A QUICKLY
BEGINNING IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN INDIVIDUALS ARE
SUPPOSED TO RELINQUISH THEIR
FIREARMS AT THE TIME OF THEIR
CONVICTION FOR A FELONY OR
CERTAIN MISDEMEANORS. AND SO WE
OPTION THAT WE PROVIDED WAS THAT
PROVIDING FUNDING TO LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT FOR PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS TO INSURE THAT THAT
WAS ACTUALLY HAPPENING AND THEY
WERE BEING SURRENDERED COULD BE
EFFECTIVE- AT LIMITING THE
GROWTH IN THE NUMBER OF ARMED
AND PROHIBITED PERSONS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU MISLI ARE WILL
MOVE ON NOW TO HEAR FROM JULIA
WEBER FROM THE GIFFORDS LAW
CENTER. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- MY NAME IS JULIA
WEBER I SERVICE IMPLEMENTATION
DIRECTOR AT DIFFERENCE LAWCENTER
AND- TEACH DOMESTIC VIOLENCE LAW
IT GOLDEN GATE UNIVERSITY SCHOOL
OF LAW. I'M APPEARING HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF GIFFORDS. AND I'VE
WORKED IN OF FOR OVER TWENTY
FIVE YEARS INCLUDING A SEVENTEEN
YEARS ITH THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
ON VIOLENCE PREVENTION ISSUES.
I'VE ALSO COLLABORATED WITH HOST
ON TRAINING FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
ON FIREARM RELINQUISHMENT. AND
BECAUSE OF THIS I KNOW HOW
CRITICAL IT IS THAT WE FUNDED
PROGRAMS TO ENSURE INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE PROHIBITED. FROM HAVING
FIREARMS ARE ACTUALLY SEPARATED
FROM THOSE FIREARMS AS CLOSE TO
THE TIME OF PROHIBITION IS
POSSIBLE. THERE ARE SO MANY
TRAGEDIES ON MY MIND TODAY.
ADULTS CHILDREN POLICE OFFICERS
COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHOSE LIVES
HAVE BEEN SHATTERED BY GUN
VIOLENCE. AND SPECIFICALLY BY
THOSE WHO REMAIN IN POSSESSION
OF FIREARMS. DESPITE BEING
PROHIBITED. LAST YEAR ROBERT
LEWIS AT CALMATTERS REVEALED THE
EXTENT OF THE PROBLEM WHEN HE
COVERED THE STORY OF KELLY GRAY
A THIRTY TWO YEAR OLD MOTHER OF
THREE WHO SOUGHT PROTECTION FROM
HER ABUSIVE HUSBAND. BY
REQUESTING A RESTRAINING ORDER
AGAINST HIM IN TWENTY TWENTY IN
MADERA. HE TOLD HER A
RESTRAINING ORDER WAS NOTHING
MORE THAN A PIECE OF PAPER AND
WOULDN'T KEEP HIM AWAY. KELLY
HAD THE COURAGE TO CHECK THE BOX
ON THE PETITION FORM FOR HER
CIVIL DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDER. INDICATING
THAT YES SHE BELIEVES THE PERSON
TO BE RESTRAINED. OWNS OR
POSSESSES GUNS FIREARMS OR
AMMUNITION. RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
THE PRESENCE OF A FIREARM IN A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CASE MAKES IT
FIVE TIMES MORE LIKELY THAT A
VICTIM WILL BE KILLED. SHE ALSO
INCLUDED MORE THAN A DOZEN PAGES
DESCRIBING HORRIFIC ABUSE AND
THROUGH IT ALL WITH MENTION OF A
GUN IN HIS POCKET WHEN HE YELLED
AT HER OUTSIDE THEIR SON'S
SCHOOL. AND WHEN HE THREATENED
TO TAKE HER INTO THE ORCHARDS
AND KILL HER. AT THE HEARING THE
JUDGE WHO HAD SAID ON THE RECORD
THAT HE HAD REVIEWED THE FILING
ASK ONLY ONE QUESTION ABOUT GUNS
. SURE THERE'S NO INFORMATION
THAT YOU HAVE ANY GUNS OR
FIREARMS OR AMMUNITION YOU THINK
YOU HAVE ANY OF THESE. NO HER
HUSBAND REPLIED. THE DELAYS WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT'S INVESTIGATION
AND AN EMERGENCY PROTECTIVE
ORDER THAT DID NOT RESULT IN ANY
GUN RELINQUISHMENT TO OR SEIZURE
BY LAW ENFORCEMENT SUGGESTS
THERE WERE MULTIPLE
OPPORTUNITIES TO INTERVENE. BUT
LESS THAN A MONTH AFTER THE
HEARING SALLY'S HUSBAND SHOT AND
KILLED HER IN FRONT OF THEIR
THREE CHILDREN AGES SIX FOUR AND
ONE. WE CAN DO MUCH BETTER. IN
CRIMINAL CASES THERE IS A
GOVERNMENT FUNDED ATTORNEYS ON
BOTH SIDES M. PROBATION MAY BE
INVOLVED TO HELP ENSURE FIREARM
RELINQUISHMENT HAPPENS BUT
FAMILY COURTS DON'T HAVE THE
STATE FUNDED RESOURCES SO JUDGES
COURT STAFF AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
ARE CRITICAL ESPECIALLY IN.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDERS OR DVR ROSE. GIFFORD
SPONSORED SB THREE TWENTY LAST
YEAR TO CLEARLY SET OUT WHAT
EVERYONE'S RESPONSIBILITIES ARE
IN THESE CASES. NOW COURTS MUST
PROVIDE INFORMATION ABOUT HOW
RESTRAINED PARTIES CAN COMPLY.
LAW ENFORCEMENT MUST REMOVE
FIREARMS IN PLAIN SIGHT OR FOUND
THROUGH A CONSENSUAL SEARCH OR
THE PARTY HAS TWENTY FOUR HOURS
TO RELINQUISH IN FORTY EIGHT
HOURS TO PROVIDE PROOF TO THE
COURT. THE OF COMPLIANCE ISN'T
PROVIDED IN THE CIVIL DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDERS. THE
COURT MUST NOTIFY LAW
ENFORCEMENT IMMEDIATELY AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT MUST TAKE ALL
ACTIONS NECESSARY TO OBTAIN THE
PARTY'S FIREARMS AND AMMUNITION.
THE COURT MUST REVIEW THE FILE
AND REPORT VIOLATIONS TO THE
PROSECUTING AGENCY WITHIN TWO
DAYS. FAMILY COURTS CONCERT
REVIEW HEARINGS AS WELL AND SOME
ARE BUT WE AREN'T SEEING ENOUGH
EXAMPLES OF THESE PRACTICES
BEING IMPLEMENTED THERE IS NO
CONSISTENT PROCESS IN OUR
COUNTIES FOR COLLECTING WEAPONS
FROM PEOPLE WITH COURT ORDERED
FIREARM PROHIBITIONS ON RELATED
TO A CRIMINAL CONVICTION. SUCH
AS D. V. ALL THOSE IN KING
COUNTY SEATTLE WASHINGTON THE
COMMUNITY BENEFITS A NORMAL
SLEEP FROM OF FIREARMS COURT
COORDINATOR. WHOSE ROLE IS TO
PROVIDE COMPREHENSIVE
INFORMATION TO THE JUDGES AND
CIVIL PROCEEDINGS. AND
COORDINATE WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO ENSURE SWIFT FOLLOW UP ON NON
COMPLIANCE WE KNOW WHAT WORKS
WHEN JURISDICTIONS DEDICATED
PERSONNEL TO ENFORCING
PROHIBITIONS AND WHEN COURTS
FOLLOW PROTOCOLS TO IMPLEMENT
ORDERS GUNS ARE TAKEN OFF THE
STREETS. YES THERE IS A LOT OF
DETAIL NUANCE AND COMPLEXITY
HERE WHAT IT COMES DOWN TO THIS.
LAWS REQUIRING VIOLENT PARTNERS
TO RELINQUISH THEIR FIREARMS ARE
LINKED TO A 16% REDUCTION IN GUN
HOMICIDES. THAT TANGIBLE BENEFIT
IS ONLY AVAILABLE IF WE FIND
IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE POLICIES
WE NEED DEDICATED LOCAL
PERSONNEL TO DEVELOP PROTOCOLS
ENSURE VICTIMS WHO OFTEN HAVE
VERY GOOD INFORMATION ABOUT THE
RESTRAINT PARTIES ACCESS TO
FIREARMS. ARE ACTUALLY HURT. NO
MATTER HOW SOMEONE BECOMES
PROHIBITED WE NEED TO ACT
QUICKLY WHEN WE IGNORE FIREARM
PROHIBITIONS WE UNDERMINE THE
POTENTIAL BENEFITS OF THE ENTIRE
ORDER. WASTING PRECIOUS
RESOURCES AND PUTTING PARTNER
PARTIES ARE AT RISK WE SEND THE
MESSAGE THAT LIES ASSEMBLY
PROTECTED BY THOSE ORDERS DON'T
MATTER. AND THAT WERE WILLING TO
RISK THE LIVES OF COMMUNITY
MEMBERS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS WHO MAY LATER ENCOUNTER
THIS ARMED PROHIBITED PERSON. WE
UNNECESSARILY INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN THE ARMORY
THE PERSON SYSTEM SIMPLY BECAUSE
OUR SYSTEM ALLOWED RESTRAIN
INDIVIDUALS. TO MAINTAIN THEIR
FIREARMS EVEN AFTER THE BREAK
PROHIBITS. IN A TO SAVING LIVES
AND EFFECTIVELY LIBERTY
RESOURCES FUNDING FOR LOCAL
FIREARMS RELINQUISHMENT WILL
ULTIMATELY INCREASE TRUST AND
CONFIDENCE IN OUR LEGAL SYSTEM'S
ABILITY TO ENHANCE PUBLIC SAFETY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE. THANK YOU
MISS WEBER ARMS WE HAVE- ALSO
STEVE LINDLEY FROM THE
ORGANIZATION BRADY. THE MANAGER
IN THE MORNING ON THE FIRST
MINISTRY LONELY AND I'M A TWENTY
SIX YEAR LAW ENFORCEMENT
EXPERIENCE AND WAS THE CHIEF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT JUSTICE
YOU'RE FINE SHE TWO THOUSAND AND
NINE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF. AND
REPRESENTATION FOR THE BRADY
CAMPAIGN FOR GUN VIOLENCE PRETTY
IS ONE OF THE AMERICA'S OLDEST
DEMONSTRATION AND OUR HISTORY
GOES BACK DECADES EACH YEAR MORE
THAN A HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR
THOUSAND AMERICANS ARE VICTIMS
OF GUN VIOLENCE MORE THAN FORTY
FIVE THOUSAND. CALIFORNIANS ARE
PROHIBITED SUCH MORE COMING ON
AFTER. PROGRAM WAS THE CENTER
ALLEGEDLY. IN NINETEEN NINETY
NINE AS A RESULT OF THE
PROLIFERATION OF GUN VIOLENCE
ACROSS THE STATE ACROSS THE
NATION. THE POST OF THE
PROGRAM'S DISARMED FELONS
MENTALLY ILL PERSONS AND OTHER
DAYS INDIVIDUALS. AB DATABASE
WENT INTO EFFECT IN DECEMBER TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT. CRAWFORD THIS IS
BYRON OWNERS ACROSS THE STATE
AGAINST CRIMINAL HISTORY RECORDS
MENTAL HEALTH RECORDS. IN
RESTRAINING ORDERS IN ORDER TO
IDENTIFY INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
BEEN OR WILL BE COMFORTED. FROM
ISN'T APART SOMETHING WHICH THE
LEGAL ACQUISITION. FOR THE
REGISTRATION OF THE FARMERS
CHOCOLATE. THIS IS A PROACTIVE
WAY TO PREVENT CRIME AND REDUCE
VIOLENCE INCLUDING INSTANCE
INSTANCE OF RESERVOIRS. THE CITY
CALIFORNIA'S A PERSON ONLY STATE
OF THE NATION TO ESTABLISH AN
AUTOMATED SYSTEM. THE CHICKEN
FARMERS WHO MIGHT FALL INTO A
PROHIBITED STATUS. THE COMPANY'S
APPS MISSION OF REMOVING
FIREARMS FROM INDIVIDUALS WHO
MAY POSE A THREAT TO THEMSELVES.
OR SHORT COMMUNITIES YOU'RE
TRAIN COMES OFF AS A SIDE DISH
UP ON. OVER THE PAST FIFTEEN
YEARS RECREATION IS IMPORTANT
PROGRAM. TO REMOVE FIREARMS
PROHIBITED INDIVIDUALS LISTED IN
THE APP SYSTEM. UNTIL TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN THE APP'S
DATABASE WAS INSTITUTIONALLY
BASED ON HANDGUN TRANSSEXUAL
DESPITE THE FACT THAT
APPROXIMATELY. HALF OF ALL
CALIFORNIA FARMS. INVOLVED LONG.
THANK YOU TO REVERSE TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN UNDER
CALIFORNIA LAW MANDATED
CORPORATE JUSTICE. COLLECTOR
CAME FARM TRANSACTION
INFORMATION FOR ALL TYPES OF
FIREARMS INCLUDING AUGUST. THIS
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED NUMBER
OF SERVERS ALL OF THE AFTER
EFFECTS. IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
ALONE I 16% OR SO GOOD FOR GAME
PERHAPS. IN THE PRIOR YEAR. TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN SENATE BILL
ONE FORTY FIVE PASSED THE
SENATE. OVERWHELMINGLY CHOOSING.
APPROXIMATED TWENTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS OVER THREE YEARS THE
FORMER JUST YOU REDUCE. OPINION
APPLICATIONS.
THIS IS SENATE BILL ONE FORTY.
THE DEPARTMENT DRESSES AND MAKE
SIGNIFICANT EFFORTS TO REDUCE
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE IS IN APPS
AS FOR HIM TO RECOVER TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF FILES. ALL OF THESE
EFFORTS ARE ROADWORTHY DO NOT
SOLVE OUR PROBLEM GOVERNMENTS
HOWEVER WITH THE LESSONS LEARNED
FROM NOW FIFTY YEARS AFTER FOR
SPRINT WE HAVE OPTIONS AVAILABLE
TO REDUCE ARRESTED AGENTS AND
RECOVERING FARMS. SUBJECT MAYBE
SEPARATE MORE COST EFFECTIVE
FROM COVER FIREARMS. FOR
PROHIBIT BURSTS. IN TWO
THOUSAND- SIXTY THREE REQUIRED
THAT YEAH. PROBATE OFFICER. ON
START INTERDICTING FIRES
PROHIBITIONS AT THE TIME OF SHE
HOWEVER THIS MAN. TO OUR COUNTY
. APARTMENT CAME WITH NO FUNDING
. WHAT WE'VE SEEN IS IN SAN
FRANCISCO- WHEN YOU LOOK AT A
FULLY FUNDED PROGRAM YOU HAVE
SUCCESS. WE NEED TO FIND WAYS TO
ASSIST THE COURTS INFORMATION
APPORTION FIREARMS AND
AMMUNITION RELINQUISHMENT AT THE
TIME. OF THE RESTRAINING ORDER
OR SENTENCE. YES THIS TAKES
EFFORT COMMITMENT AND FUNDING
OKAY WE REALLY AFFORD. NOT TO
TAKE HIS ACTIONS. WE WERE FROM A
INTEREST OF CAMANCHE BEFORE.
TWENTY FIVE COST OF VIOLENCE THE
CITY OF CA. ESTIMATED EACH FOR
IN HOMICIDE TAXPAYERS TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION. THERE'S A STRIP
CLUB REFORM FURTHER AS THE THAT
NOT. INJURIES COST TAXPAYERS A
PROCESS NINE I NINE HUNDRED IS
THOUSAND DOLLARS EACH. ACCORDING
TO THE CENTER FOR AMERICAN
PROGRESS AND A TEN YEAR PERIOD
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THERE WERE
OVER THIRTY THOUSAND FARMERS
HOMICIDES IN CALIFORNIA. USUALLY
REPORTED COST REQUIREMENT WAITED
HOMOSEXUALS THEIR STOCK AND IS
FINALLY HOME SAYS COST
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS. SEVENTY
SIX BILLION. OR POINT SIX
BILLION PER YEAR. CALIFORNIA HAS
MASON INVESTMENTS IN LIKE
PERFORMS UNIQUE THINGS EFFORTS
TO REDUCE INVITED COMMUNITIES
ROBERT STATE CALIFORNIA'S GHG
EMISSIONS REDUCE FARM WHERE
VIOLENCE AND REMOVE FIREARMS
FROM PERSONSREMOVE THEMAS
EARLY AS POSSIBLE AND DOING THAT
IN THE COURTS AND PROBATION. IS
A PERFECT EXAMPLE OF HOW WE CAN
USE OUR PARTY THANK YOU FOR THE
CONSIDERATION. TO DOUBLE THE
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU MISTER
LINDLEY I HAVE A FOR ME- WHAT
WHAT IS IT THAT WE- AS A STATE
HAVE. WHY HAVEN'T WE DONE THIS.
WHEREVER WE MOVE FORWARD ON THIS
AND YOU KNOW WHAT ARE THE WHAT
ARE THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES THAT
YOU SEE FROM OUR STATE MOVING
FORWARD. BUT I THINK ONE OF THE
COMPLEXITY THEORY IS- IS A LACK
OF RECOGNITION OF HOUSE
SIGNIFICANT THE CIVIL COURT
PROCEEDINGS ARE IN THIS AREA.
THAT IS THAT FOR EXAMPLE WE TALK
ABOUT THE ROLE OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS 97% OF THOSE
G. V. R. ROSE HAVE BEEN.
OPPOSITION FOR BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT THEY ARE OFTEN
GIARDIA THE TIME REPRESENTED BY
CITY ATTORNEYS. SO THEY'RE IN A
CIVIL COURT AND THEY'RE
PURSUING. A CIVIL RESTRAINING
ORDER BUT REALLY THE STATE IS
ACTING IN THE MAJORITY OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDERS WERE LOOKING AT THE VAST
MAJORITY SELF REPRESENTED
LITIGANTS. NO ATTORNEY
REPRESENTING THE PARTY TO BE
RESTRAINED. ARE THERE'S JUST THE
JUDGE. MET HOPEFULLY A BAILIFF.
TOO OFTEN NOT EVEN A COURT
REPORTER SO NO PROBATION AND NO
LAW ENFORCEMENT INVOLVEMENT I
AND THAT MEANS THAT A LOT FALLS
ON THE JUDGE. AND SORT OF YOU
KNOW CROSSING YOUR FINGERS AND
HOPING PEOPLE COMPLY- UNLESS WE
FIND SOMETHING LIKE A FIREARMS.
RELINQUISHMENT COORDINATOR AND
LAST WEEK PASSED POLICIES THAT
REQUIRE THAT THE COURT ACTS SO
THERE'S BEEN I'D SAY SOME REAL
THE COLLECT OF THE FIREARM
PROHIBITIONS IN THE CIVIL
CONTEXT AND THAT'S WHERE THE
MAJORITY IF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
GOES TO COURT IT MORE OFTEN IT'S
GOING TO BE IN FAMILY CIVIL
COURT THAN CRIMINAL COURT. SO WE
HAVE TO TURN OUR ATTENTION I
THINK THE CIVIL PROCEEDINGS- AND
JUST DO A BETTER JOB
COORDINATING SO THAT NO MATTER
WHAT DOOR YOU WALK THROUGH IN
TERMS OF HOW YOU GET PROHIBITED
WE CONSISTENTLY INSURER FIREARMS
ARE RELINQUISHED RECEIVES. THANK
YOU. MOST CENTER SENATOR NEWMAN-
THANK YOU MEASURE SHOW- FOR
MUSLIM THE IDEA OF YOU KNOW THAT
THE ANECDOTE YOU YOU TOLD ABOUT
THE INCIDENT IN MADERA JIM IS
TRULY TERRIFYING I GUESS FOR YOU
OR MR I'M SORRY MISS WEBER-
MISTER LINDLEY THE DO WE HAVE
DATA I MEAN IT SEEMS IT SEEMS
FAIRLY OBVIOUS RIGHT IN THE
PROBLEM YOU DESCRIBE IS REAL-
BUT YOU KNOW THE- THE APS SYSTEM
REALLY SUFFERS FROM YOU. WE
CONTRACT REGISTERED WEAPONS BUT
NOT UNREGISTERED WEAPONS SEEMS
TO BE PRETTY LIKELY THE KINDS
PEOPLE GET INTO YOU KNOW THE
DOMESTIC DISPUTES RETARDER
PRETTY LIKE THAT OF UNREGISTERED
WEAPONS- WHAT DO WE KNOW WHAT
WHAT DO WE HAVE DATA ON YOU KNOW
THOSE. YOU KNOW THE FREQUENCY IN
WHICH- SOMEBODY WHO IS THE
TARGET RESTRAINING ORDER
ACTUALLY DOES HAVE UNREGISTERED
WEAPONS AND YOU KNOW THEY'RE
THEY'RE OBVIOUSLY PROBLEMS IN
RELINQUISHMENT OF THROUGH THAT
HOST BUT DO YOU KNOW GOING TO A
HOME GOING INTO A RESIDENTIAL
SOMEWHERE IN AND DOING A SWEEP
FOR WEAPONS. TO YOUR ME SO WE
ASK THE QUESTIONS TO MR POINT
EARLY DO YOU HAVE. WEAPONS SO
WITH WHAT WE HAVE BY WAY OF
DATA- TO SUPPORT- A SMARTER
EVIDENCED BASED APPROACH ON
THIS. WELL I THINK I THINK THAT
IS WHAT THE COMPLEXITIES HERE IS
THAT. WHEN WE ASK THE FOR. THE
PROTECTED PARTY OR THE PERSON
REQUESTING A RESTRAINING ORDER.
WE OFTEN GET A TON OF
INFORMATION AND IN FACT I GET
CALLS AND EMAILS REGULARLY FROM-
THE HANDFUL OF ATTORNEYS WHO ARE
REPRESENTING VICTIMS- RECORDING
YOU KNOW LOTS OF. EVIDENCE BEING
PRESENTED IN THE PETITIONS THAT
SPEAK TO. THE PERSON HAVING
UNREGISTERED. A POST PICTURES
THEMSELVES ON FACEBOOK THEY TELL
PEOPLE THEY SOMETIMES EVEN
TESTIFY OF A LIST OF CASES WHERE
THEY'VE SAID SURE. SHE'S NOT NOW
LYING- BUT WE STILL DON'T SEEM
ABLE TO REALLY FOCUS ON TAKING
THOSE NEXT STEPS AND I'D SAY
STEVE- MISTER LINDLEY MAY BE IN
A BETTER POSITION TO PROVIDE ANY
ACTUAL DATA ON. UNREGISTERED
FIREARMS I JUST KNOW THAT WHEN
THERE IS MAYBE ONE FIREARM THAT
SHOWS UP IN THE- AUTOMATED
FIREARMS SYSTEM TOO OFTEN IT
TURNS OUT THAT THERE'S A WHOLE
BUNCH OF OTHER FIREARMS. THAT
THE PROTECTED PARTY OF THE PARTY
SEEKING PROTECTION. TRIES TO
TELL THE COURT ABOUT OR KNOWS
ABOUT. THAT WE CAN ONLY GET
BETTER INFORMATION ABOUT IF WE
ARE IN TOUCH WITH THEM IN
ADDITION TO. THE PERSON TO BE
RESTRAINED BUT I DON'T KNOW
STEVE IF YOU WANT TO ADD
ANYTHING ABOUT THAT.
UNREGISTERED SO EARLY ON ME OUT
FROM AROUND THERE IS A RESEARCH
DONE BY A DOCTOR YOU SEE DAVIS-
WERE RELATED TO COUNTIES AND HOW
THEY RECOVERED FIREARMS OF ONE
OF THE- WHEN DID PROGRAMS WAS
FOUR. ENFORCEMENT TO INTERVIEW
TO PROTECT PARTLY ABOUT HOW MANY
FIREARMS- THE- OTHER INDIVIDUAL
MIGHT HAVE OFTENTIMES THE
OTTOMAN A FARM SYSTEM THAT MIGHT
HAVE ONE OR TWO WIRELESS THAT
SYSTEM. BUT END UP HAVING A
HUNTER TWENTY FIREARMS-
ACTUALLY- OTHER RESIDENTS- OVER
THE TIME OF THE APPS PROGRAM A
VAST MAJORITY OF THE FIREARMS
ARE RECOVERED- FROM PROHIBIT
INDIVIDUALS. ARE NOT LISTED IN
THE FARM SYSTEM. THAT THEY I'M
NECESSARILY. ON REGISTERED WAR
THAT THEY WERE PURCHASED
ILLEGALLY IT'S JUST THAT THE
SYSTEM DIDN'T TRACK LONGER IN
CELLS BEFORE TWENTY FOURTEEN.
AND DIDN'T S. ACCURATELY.
REFLECT AND TRACK. GOOD CELLS
BEFORE NINETEEN SIX SO FARMS ARE
TIME HELPING PROTECT. SO THESE
DON'T AS WE WOULD LIKE JUST OF
THE ONLY DO WHAT THE LAW ALLOWS
YOU. WHAT A **** BEFORE COVERED
AFTER THIS IS A- OR NOT LET'S IN
IN THE ESTATE I HAVEN'T VIRUSES
. CHOI IF YOUR THE SUBJECT OF A
RESTRAINING ORDER IN YOUR BEFORE
A JUDGE THE JUDGE JESSICA JERRY
ARE YOU UNDER OATH WHEN YOU
ANSWER THE QUESTION WHAT ARE
THE- PENALTIES FOR MANAGING A
QUESTION. FALSELY YOU ARE UNDER
OATH YES YOU'RE UNDER OATH IT'S
PENALTY OF PERJURY. OF AND YOU
KNOW. IT YOU ARE OFTEN. OF
RESTRAINED AS WELL- BECAUSE
THERE MAY BE AN EX PARTE ORDER
IN PLACE OR AN EMERGENCY
PROTECTIVE ORDER- MAY HAVE BEEN
ISSUED- IN UNDER THE PANDEMIC
RULES THOSE WERE EXTENDED- ARE
PROHIBITED AT THOSE POINTS AS
WELL- AND YET WE HAVE NOT.
TO YOUR POINTS THE FOLLOW UP
THAT MATTERS NOPE NO PREACHER
YANKEE MANAGER AND THE- THE
PROPOSAL I'M SORRY DID YOU HAVE
A QUESTION COMING. UP JUST IN
TERMS OF HOW THE FUNDING WOULD
BE USED ARE YOU MENTIONED-
PROBATION GOING TO PROBATION OR
LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT THERE'D BE
A BIGGER ROLE WOULD THAT MEAN.
THE FOR THE WEDDING WOULD GO
TOWARDS MORE. BALONNE FORSMAN
PERSONNEL OR MORE PROBATION
PERSONNEL FILE A DIFFERENT
STANDPOINT WHAT WE'RE REALLY
FOCUSING ON IS NOT SO MUCH
PROBATION- BUT WHAT I MENTIONED
IN TERMS OF THE EXAMPLE FROM
KING COUNTY SEATTLE WASHINGTON
WHICH IS A COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH YOU KNOW- THE FACT THE
PROBATION PLAYS A ROLE IN THE
CRIMINAL PROCEEDINGS UNDER PROP
SIXTY THREE WHERE THEY HAVE TO
ENSURE FIREARM RELINQUISHMENT
HAPPENS AND THEY HAVE TO TELL.
LOCAL WE WILL BE A SIMILAR. IN
CIVIL PROCEEDINGS IN FOR EXAMPLE
THESE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDER PROCEEDINGS SO
SOMETHING LIKE A FIREARMS
RELINQUISHMENT COORDINATOR WHOSE
JOB IT WOULD BE TO ENSURE THAT
PROTOCOLS ARE IN PLACE. THE
JUDGES GET THE INFORMATION THEY
NEED THERE ARE CERTAIN
BACKGROUND CHECKS THAT ARE
EXPECTED TO BE PERFORMED UNDER
FAMILY CODE SECTION SIX THREE OH
SIX IN FAMILY LAW DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE PROCEEDINGS. THAT WOULD
GET THEIR JOBS BETTER
INFORMATION THEY COULD BE
LOOKING AT CRIMINAL DATABASE
CASE MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS TO
ENSURE THAT SOMEONE ISN'T REVIEW
NO PROHIBITED IN CRIMINAL. ON
PROBATION AND THAT INFORMATION
ISN'T GIVEN TO THE FAMILY COURT.
WILL BE COORDINATING WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT SO WE REALLY SEE THE
NEED TO HAVE DEDICATED PERSON IN
EVERY COURT. R. THAT WORKS WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT PROBATION AND
THE CIVIL COURTS TO ENSURE
BETTER COORDINATION SO THAT
WOULD BE OUR OUR EMPHASIS OKAY.
OKAY SIR COURTESY. THANK YOU
MA'AM SURE- FIRST OF ALL. I'M
I'M REALLY HAPPY TO SEE. YOU
KNOW MORE ENERGY GOING INTO THE
SIDE OF THINGS- IN A I'M NOT
ASKING ANYONE TO AGREE WITH YOU
BUT I JUST THINK THAT. YOU KNOW
SO MUCH HAS BEEN SO MUCH ENERGY
AND LEGISLATION AN EFFORT HAS
BEEN PUT INTO WHAT I WOULD CALL
THE HARDWARE SIDE OF. OF FIRE
ARMS CONTROL AND- TRYING TO
DETERMINE WHAT'S SAFER YOU KNOW
GUNS WITH. SMALL CLUBS OR LARGE
GROUPS AND ALL THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS WHEN- THE FACT THE MATTER
IS THAT WE'RE WE'RE JUST DOING.
AN EXTRAORDINARILY- ANEMIC JOB
OF GETTING GUNS OUT OF THE HANDS
OF PEOPLE THAT ARE SUPPOSED TO
HELP ME IN THE FIRST PLACE-
REGARDLESS OF. REGARDLESS OF
WHAT THE HARDWARE LOOKS LIKE OR
FEELS LIKE- IN IN. IN ALSO I
JUST THINK AS A- EDITORIAL
STATEMENT YOU KNOW THIS APPROACH
RELEASE. STEERS AWAY FROM FOLKS
WHO ARE MORE HEALTHY LAW ABIDING
FIREARMS OWNERS WHO WHO AREN'T-
YOU KNOW IN THE SYSTEM THAT
WE'VE BEEN DESCRIBING SYSTEMS
THAT WE'VE BEEN DESCRIBING ALL
ALONG SO. GREAT THE COUPLE JUST
A COUPLE. COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS
ONE OF THEM IS I HAD A- THE
CONSTITUENT OF A COUPLE OF YEARS
AGO WHO- WAS FIFTY ONE FIFTIES
IN A- MENTAL HEALTH. THIS
FACILITY IN A MEDICAL FACILITY-
WHO THEN HAD THE OJ SHOW UP- AT
HIS HOUSE AND- SAY- YOU HAVE A
REGISTERED FIREARM WE NEED IT
AND IT'S GONNA OUTLINED HERE IN
THE PACKET HOW THAT HOW THAT
GOES YOU CAN- TRANSMITTERS FOR
SOMEBODY ELSE OR OR GIVE IT UP
OR THEY CAN STORE FOR USE. AS A
RECALL THAT THE INDIVIDUAL WAS
VERY COOPERATIVE SO I SHOULDN'T
HAVE THE FIREARM- BUT CONTACTED
ME WITH QUESTIONS ABOUT. WHY HIS
MEDICAL INFORMATION IN THE
FACILITY WAS IN WASN'T PROTECTED
IN OTHER WORDS THAT THE DOJ
FOLKS KNEW HIS MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITION- SO ONE QUESTION I
HAVE IS WHETHER OR NOT THAT'S
CREATING ANY COMPLEXITY AT ALL
MAYBE. YOU KNOW WE HAVE THE
CHALLENGE AND I KNOW A LOT OF
FIFTY ONE FIFTIES HAPPEN. ON THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT SIDE VERSUS THE-
OF MEDICAL PROVIDER SIDE OR THE
SOCIAL WORKER SIDE BUT- DID IT
WELL I NEVER COULD GET A GOOD
QUITE A GOOD ANSWER TO THAT
QUESTION. ON ON THE CONSTITUENTS
BEHALF HOWEVER IN THIS IS A
SUBWAY. I SPOKE TO THE ACTUAL-
THE ACTUAL DOJ OFFICER. WHO HAD
SHOWED SHOWED UP AT THE HOUSE-
WHO- WHO HAD REQUESTED THE
RELINQUISHMENT. IN IN-
CONSISTENT TO SOME DEGREE WITH
THIS WHOLE PRESENTATION TODAY-
HE SAID THE BIGGER QUESTION IS-
IT WITH FELONIES WITH WITH WITH.
ALL OF THE THINGS W TALKED
ABOUT TODAY THAT WOULD. GIVE
RISE TO A LEGAL PROHIBITION OF
FOR AN INDIVIDUAL LEVEL FIREARM
ASIDE FOR MENTAL HEALTH. THAT
THEY WERE. WERE TO DOJ OFFICERS
FOR THE BAY AREA THAT WERE
RESPONSIBLE WERE ASSIGNED TO THE
RELINQUISHMENT PROGRAM. AND I
DON'T REMEMBER I HAVE TO ADMIT
THIS COUPLE YEARS AGO THE NUMBER
OF CASES HE SAID THAT THEY HAD
IN THE DATABASE THAT THEY WERE.
CHARGED WITH PURSUING BUT IT
WAS- BUT AN EXTRAORDINARILY HIGH
NUMBER YOU KNOW FAR BEYOND WHAT
- ANY PERSON HE WROTE A PERSON
EVEN A CHILD WOULD PROBABLY SAY
IMMEDIATELY THERE'S NO WAY
YOU'RE GOING TO GET TO ALL
THOSE- SO PART OF MY QUESTION
WHICH IS. ANOTHER ONE OF BE
REDUNDANT TO WHAT THE CHURCH'S
ASKED BUT YOU KNOW ABOUT HOW
THESE DOLLARS ARE INVESTED ON
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL SAY THEY
COULD SEE. THE OF YOU KNOW THE
EMPHASIS ON THE COORDINATOR
SPECIALLY ON THE FAMILY LOST
SIGHT OF INTERCEPTING NO. I
THINK NO. NO THERE SHOULD BE AN
ABSOLUTE NO WIGGLE ROOM IN
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CASES- YOU
KNOW FOR ANYONE TO CONTINUE.
HOLDING A FIRM THAT SENT A
RESTRAINING ORDER- OR OR OTHER
EVIDENCE OF DVD- BUT BEYOND THAT
- HIS IS THIS. APPROACH THAT
WERE BEING. THEY WERE LOOKING AT
TODAY AS PART OF ITS
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH IN A KISS
IN THIS MAYBE THESE QUESTIONS OR
OFFER MISS GIVE MISS WILL HAS
WEBER SORRY OF THIS WEBER- IS
THERE IS PART OF. THE REQUESTED
OR WHERE WE WANT TO GO HI I'M
TRYING TO BOLSTER UP THE F. T.
E. IN THE DOJ IN TERMS OF THE
NUMBER OF FOLKS THAT ARE JUST
GOING OUT DOING THE WORK AGES
IT'S IT SEEMS SO CLEAR TO ME
THAT. THERE'S YOU KNOW EVEN IF
YOU TOOK MENTAL HEALTH OUT OF IT
TEMPORARILY SUGGESTED APPROVED
SAYING THAT THEY HAD SO MANY
CASES TO PURSUE THAT YOU KNOW
EASILY EXPANDING THE RANKS BY BY
FIVE TIMES OR TEN TIMES WOULD
WOULD NOT OF BEEN LAVISH
RELATIVE TO THE SIZE OF THE
PROBLEM BUT I HAVEN'T REALLY
HEARD ANYONE SPEAK TO THAT.
SPECIFIC NEED. WELL SO- I AM
CERTAINLY AS SOMEONE WHO WORKED
IN GOVERNMENT FOR A LONG TIME
I'M THE LAST PERSON WHO'S GONNA
SAY THERE ARE ENOUGH RESOURCES
AND CERTAINLY- EXAMPLE. SPEAKS
TO THE FACT THAT THERE ARE
PROBABLY THIS IS A SERIOUS
CONCERN ABOUT LACK OF RESOURCES
IN TERMS OF WHAT YOU'RE
DESCRIBING- IS THE APPS
ENFORCEMENT UNITS- WHAT IT IS
THAT THE DOJ LEVEL BUT WHAT I'M
MOST. CONCERNED ABOUT IS THAT
THOSE FOLKS END UP WITH A LOT
MORE ON THEIR PLATE I WE DON'T
ACT. IMMEDIATELY AS CLOSE TO THE
TIME OF PROHIBITION AS POSSIBLE
WHICH MEANS. UTILIZING LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND LOCAL COURT
PERSONNEL RIGHT SO IF WE DO A
BETTER JOB WHICH MAKES MORE
SENSE IN TERMS OF THE INCREASED
RISK AND DANGER THE LONGER WE
DELAY- AGAIN KING COUNTY SEATTLE
WASHINGTON IS AN EXCELLENT
EXAMPLE OF THIS. THAT WAS THE
WHOLE FOCUS REDUCING THE TIME
BETWEEN WHEN SOMEONE BECOMES
PROHIBITED AND WE ALREADY HAVE
LAWS IN PLACE TWENTY FOUR HOURS
TO RELINQUISH. FORTY EIGHT HOURS
TO PROVIDE TO THE COURT AND
UNDER SB THREE TWENTY. THE COURT
SHOULD BE LOOKING AT THAT FILE
IMMEDIATELY WITHIN THAT TIME
FRAME NOTICING SOMEONE HASN'T
COMPLIED AND THEN REPORTING THAT
TO LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT. AND
THE LOCAL PROSECUTING AGENCY SO
A LOT OF THIS HAS TO HAPPEN
LOCALLY. SO WE'RE SUPPORTIVE OF
IMPROVING THE ACCESS TO RESOURCE
FOR FOLKS LOCALLY IN CONJUNCTION
WITH IN COORDINATION WITH THE
WELL TRAINED. YOU KNOW NOT
ENOUGH PEOPLE IN APPS THE DOJ
AND SUPPORT THESE LOCAL EFFORTS
WITH EVEN THE ARMED PROHIBITED
PERSONS LEGISLATIVE RECORD.
INSISTENTLY SAYS. WHILE THEY'RE
ASKING FOR FUNDING. IF ONE DAY
THEY CONSISTENTLY SAID THAT
REPORT WE HAVE TO MOVE.
THE LOCAL LEVEL TWO MORE
IMMEDIATELY. ENSURE.
RELINQUISHMENT HALF. THE I'M YOU
SEE BOTH AND I MEAN THEY'RE BUT
THEY'RE BOTH NEEDED- APPS- ARE.
IF WILL AND- AND IN THE VOCAL
COORDINATION THIS THIS.
PRESENTATION TODAY THIS THIS
BUDGET REQUEST THOSE IS FOCUSED
ON THE LOCAL SIDE IS THAT
CORRECT COMMISSION UNDERSTAND IN
A MINUTE YES THAT CERTAINLY FROM
OUR STANDPOINT THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
SEEKING ARETHE FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS OVER THREE YEARS WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE ALLOCATED IN A
WAY THAT SUPPORTED LOCAL
EFFORTS- IF PRIMARILY LOOKING AT
COURT COORDINATION TO IMPROVE
BETWEEN THE CIVIL AND CRIMINAL
SYSTEMS- RELINQUISHMENT SO THAT
AGAIN NO MATTER HOW YOU GET
PROHIBITED. THERE'S AN
EXPECTATION IS THAT THEY'LL BE
FOLLOW THROUGH AND FOLLOW
THROUGH THAT INCLUDES INFORMING
RESTRAINED PERSONS ABOUT HOW
THEY CAN COMPLY WHAT WILL HAPPEN
IF THEY DON'T IT IS YOUR YOUR
INITIAL- DESCRIPTION OF THE
CASE- INVOLVING A FIFTY ONE
FIFTY SITUATION I WOULD WANT
THAT INDIVIDUAL TO HAVE BEEN
INFORMED ABOUT THE PROHIBITION.
TO HAVE INFORMATION ABOUT HOW
THEY COULD COMPLY- IF THAT WAS
POSSIBLE I UPON RELEASE OR SO
FORTH AND THEN- MAKE SURE THAT%
THEY UNDERSTOOD WHY THAT%
INFORMATION MIGHT BE SHARED AND
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN. IF THEY DID
NOT COMPLY BECAUSE THAT'S A BIG
PIECE OF SB THREE TWENTY IS
ENSURING THAT RESTRAIN PARTIES
GET EVERY OPPORTUNITY TO LOCALLY
RELINQUISH AND COMPLY TO AVOID
UNNECESSARY EXPOSURE TO THE
CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM AND AVOID
THIS DELAY THAT PUT THEIR BODY
AT RISK. I. FOR WHAT IT'S WORTH
I AGREE WITH THAT LAST SENTIMENT
ENTIRELY IN IN THAT PARTICULAR
CASE I WAS TELLING YOU ABOUT WAS
IT WAS A YOUNG MAN WHO WAS
REALLY SCARED TO DEATH- JUST HAD
BEEN DISCHARGED RECENTLY WAS NOT
REALLY UNDERSTANDING. WHY YOU
KNOW ARMED FOLKS WERE AT HIS
HOUSE YOU KNOW ASKING HIM ALL
THESE QUESTIONS BECAUSE THERE
HAD BEEN NO PRIOR. THE.
INFORMATION EDUCATION ABOUT. ANY
CREDIBLE AND REALLY WHO WHO WAS
. THE YOU KNOW THE WAS VERY
CLEAR IN IN HOW. CAME ACROSS
WHICH IS WHICH IS WHY ACTUALLY-
REACHED OUT TO- THE OFFICERS
THEMSELVES TO HAVE A TALK THEM
AND FIND OUT WHY THEY WERE
BEHAVING THAT WAY- BUT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND HOPEFULLY. YOU
KNOW SOMEBODY OR SOMEHOW DOJ CAN
COME IN FOR. AUGMENTATION AS
WELL SO THAT THINGS ARE WORKING
ON YOU KNOW HITTING ON ALL
CYLINDERS HERE THANK YOU. OKAY
IN NEWMAN ANYTHING I JUST ONE
LAST THING I DO I THINK TO-
MISTER LOWEST POINT OF THE YOU
KNOW THE ONE OF THE BIG PROBLEMS
IN CALIFORNIA'S ON RAISE YOUR
FILES ONE OF THE PROBLEMS IS
THOSE WHO HAVE PURCHASED PERHAPS
LEGALLY A FIREARM GOING TO
PURCHASE AN ASTOUNDING NUMBER OF
ILLEGAL FIREARMS AND WE ARE
DOING A TERRIBLE JOB- IN
TRACKING THOSE GENERALLY BUT BUT
OBVIOUSLY SEIZING THEM WHEN THE
TIME IS PERMITS YOU TO MISS
WEBBER'S POINT OF YOU KNOW ANY
RESOURCES WE CAN PROVIDE FOR
BETTER FOLLOW UP FOR BETTER
SYSTEMIC APPROACH- HE DO YOU
KNOW WE NEED TO DO THAT AND SO
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS DOESN'T
SEEM LIKE A SMALL DOWN PAYMENT
ON THAT. THANK YOU. WILL I ALSO
DID WAY OF THE- FACTS HERE THAT
WAS MOST. IMPRESSIVE IS- THIS IS
THE ABSENCE ABOUT INDIVIDUALS
WHO LEGALLY PURCHASED OR
REGISTER THE FIREARMS BUT THEN
IT BECAME PROHIBITIVE FOR THEM
TO CONTINUE TO OWNER OR POSSESS
THAT WENT FROM TEN THOUSAND TO
ALMOST TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND ALL
GUNS OUT THERE THAT WERE LEGALLY
BOUGHT. LEGALLY REGISTERED BUT
BECAME- THOSE INDIVIDUALS- WERE
NOT PROHIBITED THAT'S A LOT OF
THAT'S A LOT OF PEOPLE OUT THERE
WITH GUNS IT SHOULDN'T HAVE
THEMSELVES OF MISS WEBER THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR ALL YOUR WORK
WE'RE GOING TO BE TRY TO BE AS
HELPFUL AS POSSIBLE ON THIS
ISSUE THAT YOU'RE CHAMPIONING
THANK YOU MISTER LINDLEY AS WELL
FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK- NEED
THERE'S NO MORE QUESTIONS WILL.
MOVE ON. ISSUE FIVE OF VICTIM
SERVICES- MISS THE CITY WAS
GOING TO PRESENT THAT IS THAT
MISS PETERS. YES THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR JUSTIN PETERS WHAT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AND
STAFF HAS ASKED- I ASKED TO
BRIEFLY INTRODUCE. THIS I'M THIS
ITEM DOES SENATE IS CONSIDERING
PROPOSALS TO EXPAND SERVICES TO
VICTIMS OF CRIME. THE PROPOSAL
IS BEING CONSIDERED TODAY
INCLUDE AN IMMEDIATE FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM VARIOUS
CHANGES TO ELIGIBILITY AND
COMPENSATION LIMITS FOR THE
VICTIMS COMPENSATION PROGRAM.
ADDITIONAL RIGHT FOR THE
RESTITUTION FUND AND FUNDING TO
EXPAND SERVICES LIKE TRAUMA
RECOVERY CENTERS YOUR AGENDA
LAYS OUT INFORMATION ON AND
BACKGROUND ON THE STATE'S
VICTIMS PROGRAM CITIES PROPOSALS
EACH FIVE WOMEN AND I BELIEVE
THAT YOU HAVE I'M OTHER FOLKS AT
THE- HEARING TODAY THAT WILL
SPEAK TO MARK THE TENTH. THANK
YOU. THANK U. S. B. OF WE
WELCOME ED LEE FROM CA SURVEY
FOR. AND JUSTICE GOOD MORNING
MISTER LITTLE. MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND SENATORS MY NAME IS A
LITTLE AND I AM A GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS MANAGER FOR CRIME
SURVIVORS FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE
. SURVIVORS TO SAFETY AND
JUSTICE FIESTAS J. THE FLAGSHIP
PROGRAM OF ALLIANCE FOR SAFETY
AND JUSTICE AND CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE. REPRESENTS A
GROWING NETWORK OF MORE THAN
NINETY THOUSAND FROM SURVIVORS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY IN TWELVE
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA SURVIVORS.
ADVOCATING FOR NEW SAFETY
SOLUTIONS. CS IS J. BELIEVE THAT
ALSO BY THE AND SHOULD HAVE THE
RIGHT TO TRAUMA RECOVERY.
CALIFORNIA HAS TAKEN IMPORTANT
STEPS TO IMPROVE THE DELIVERY OF
SERVICES TO CRIME SURVIVORS. AND
TO ADVANCE NEW PUBLIC SAFETY
AGENDA RUTIN HEALING. FIERCEST
J. HAS BEEN AT THE FOREFRONT OF
THIS WERE MOVING LONG
MARGINALIZED SURVIVOR VOICES TO
THE CENTER OF THIS CONVERSATION
. BUT WITH MILLIONS OF RESIDENTS
IMPACTED BY VIOLENCE EVERY YEAR
THE STATE MUST DO MORE TO
ADDRESS THE SCALE OF THE NEEDS
EXISTING IN THE DISCRIMINATORY
BARRIERS TO SUPPORT. WE APPLAUD
THE SENATE FOR CONSIDERING THE
VICTIM SERVICES PROPOSAL FROM
YOU TODAY. THE BURDEN OF VIOLENT
VICTIMIZATION. IS NOT BORNE
EQUALLY IN THE UNITED STATES AND
MARGINALIZED SURVIVORS ARE MORE
LIKELY TO BE DENIED HEALTH.
NATIONALLY ROUGHLY ONE INCHES
SURVIVORS OF VIOLENCE RECEIVE
DIRECT ASSISTANCE FROM A VICTIM
SERVICE AGENCY. EIGHT TWENTY
NINETEEN SURVEY OF CALIFORNIA
CRIME SURVIVORS FOUND THAT ONLY
14% OF SURVIVORS FELT. SUPPORT
BY THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
AFTER THE EXPERIENCE CRIME.
SURVIVORSERIES HELP FOLLOWING
THE VICTIMIZTION. THEY ARE MORE
LIKELY TO RECEIVE IT FROM
FRIENDS AND FAMILY FOR A
HOSPITAL THEN FROM THE CRIMINAL
LEGAL SYSTEM STUDIES SHOW THE
SURVIVORS OVERWHELMINGLY NEED
SUPPORT MEETING BASIC NEEDS
FOLLOWING A CRIME. PROVIDING
FINANCIAL RESOURCES TO SURVIVORS
CAN HELP SURVIVORS STABLE THAT.
TO GET TO SAFETY AND
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE THE RISK OF
DEVELOPING PTSD. WITHOUT SUPPORT
SURVIVORS MAY HAVE TO SCRAMBLE
TO RAISE FUNDS TO COVER CRITICAL
EXPERIENCE EXPENSES WHILE
TRAUMATIZED READ OR NOT GET THE
HELP THEY NEED AT ALL.
ACCEPTABLE FINANCIAL SUPPORT IS
A CRITICAL COMPONENT OF HEALING
AND RECOVERY AND SHOULD BE
CENTRAL TO A COMPREHENSIVE
STRATEGY TO SUPPORT SURVIVORS.
THE SUPPORTS COMPLIMENT OTHER
CRITICAL NEEDS INCLUDING
ACCESSIBLE FROM RECOVERY
SERVICES HOUSING EMPLOYMENT AND
IMMIGRATION PROTECTIONS
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE PROGRAMS AND
OTHER PATHWAYS TO HEALING FOR
SURVIVORS. DESPITE SUBSTANTIAL
INCREASES IN CRIMINAL JUSTICE
EXPENDITURES OVER THE PAST THREE
DECADES THE MAJORITY OF TERM
SURVIVORS DO NOT RECEIVE SUPPORT
TO HELP THEM RECOVER FROM HARM.
THE STATE SPENDING ON VICTIM
SERVICES REPRESENT ABOUT 1% OF
WHAT THE STATE SPENDS ON THE
PRISON SYSTEM. IN OTHER WORDS
CALIFORNIA SPENDS NEARLY EIGHTY
TIMES MORE ON PRISONS THEN ARMED
SERVICES FOR CRIME SURVIVORS.
WELL CALIFORNIA'S VICTIMS
COMPENSATION. PROGRAM IS IN MANY
WAYS A NATIONAL LEADER SURVIVORS
ENTITLED TO COMPENSATION STILL
FACE HURDLES ACCESS. THOUSANDS
OF PLANES ARE DENIED EACH YEAR A
RECENT ANALYSIS HAS FOUND THAT
THE TYPES OF COMPENSATION
ELIGIBILITY RESTRICTIONS
CALIFORNIA HAVE. INCLUDING
CONVICTION BASED RESTRICTIONS
THE KNOWLEDGE OF ALLEGED LACK OF
COOPERATION AND RESTRICTIONS
BASED ON THE LATEST VICTIM
CONTRIBUTION TO VICTIMIZATION.
CONTRIBUTE TO AN EQUITABLE RATES
OF THE NILES FOR OUR STATE'S
MOST VULNERABLE. FIFTY THESE
REASONS AND MANY MORE FIERCE IS
J. ISN'T SUPPORT OF THE VICTIM
SERVICES BUDGET. PROPOSALS PUT
FORTH BY THE SAME WE STRONGLY
RECOMMEND THAT THE STATE PROVIDE
LOCALIZED FLEXIBLE EMERGENCY
CASH ASSISTANCE TO DIRECTLY
SUPPORT SURVIVORS. EIGHT TWENTY
NINETEEN SURVEY FROM CALIFORNIA
FROM SURVIVORS FOUND THAT MORE
THAN HALF WOULD HAVE WARRANTED
WE NEVER RECEIVE FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE FROM THE CURRENT.
STEADY CHAU SURVIVES THE VIOLENT
CRIMES PARTICULARLY LOW INCOME
SURVIVORS OVERWHELMINGLY NEEDS
TO FOR MEETING BASIC NEEDS
FOLLOWING THE CRIME. PROVIDING
FINANCIAL RESOURCES TO SURVIVORS
CAN HELP SURVIVORS STABILIZE AND
GET TO SAFETY. THE STATE'S
VICTIMS COMPENSATION PROGRAM IS
ONE TWO. BUT DUE TO VARIOUS
DECIDE SURVIVORS EVER ACCESS
THESE PHONES. EVEN THOUGH
SURVIVORS WHO MAKE MUST NAVIGATE
OVERWHELMINGLY PAPERWORK AND
RESTRICTIONS THAT MIMIC THE
CURRENT RESOURCES THEY ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR. MAYBE COME TO
DISCOURAGE IN THE OPT OUT
ALTOGETHER. THE PROGRAM ALSO
MOVES SLOWLY MISTER BARBER NEEDS
ARE OFTEN URGE. IT CAN TAKE MANY
MONTHS FOR SURVIVORS TO GET THE
ASSISTANCE FROM THE COMPENSATION
PROGRAM. LOCAL IMMEDIATE NEEDS
I'M FUNDS FOR DIRECT CASH
ASSISTANCE IDEALLY BASED
INTERESTED COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS CAN SUPPLEMENT
COMPENSATION AND FLEXIBLY SERVES
SURVIVORS WHO ARE MORE MOST AND
LEAST SUPPORTED BY EXISTING
SYSTEMS. COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE ROOTED IN
COMMUNITIES MOST HARMED BY
VIOLENCE AND LEAST SUPPORTED BY
THE LEGAL SYSTEM ARE UNIQUELY
EQUIPPED TO GET FINANCIAL
RESOURCES TO THE SURVIVORS WHO
NEED THE MOST QUICKLY. REGARDING
THE VICTIMS COMPENSATION
PROGRESS. TOO OFTEN BURDENSOME
RED TAPE MEANS THAT EVEN
SURVIVORS WHO ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
APPROVED MAY NOT GET THE HELP
THEY NEED THIS BY CALIFORNIA
BEING THE STATE WITH THE SECOND
LARGEST COST OF LIVING IN THE
COUNTRY CALIFORNIANS
COMPENSATION PROGRAM LESS THAN
NEARLY EVERY OTHER IN THE
COUNTRY IN COMPENSATION TO
SURVIVORS PER APPLICATION
APPROVED IN A YEAR. THIS IS IN
LARGE PART IS BECAUSE MOST
SURVIVORS WHO HAVE AN
APPLICATION APPROVED NEVER
ACTUALLY SUCCESSFULLY SUBMIT A
BILL FOR REIMBURSEMENT. THE
REIMBURSEMENT BASED MODEL FOR
MANY EXPENSE SINCE SIMPLY
DOESN'T WORK FOR SURVIVORS WHO
DON'T HAVE THE MONEY TO PAY FOR
EMERGENCY OR UNEXPECTED COSTS
LIKE FUNERALS. OR RE ALLOCATION
OF FROM. WHEN WE LAUNCHED OUR WE
ARE SURVIVORS CAMPAIGN WE FOUND
VICTIMS AS YOUNG AS SEVEN YEARS
OF. FUNDRAISING TO PAY FOR
FUNERAL EXPENSES THIS IS
DEHUMANIZING. AN OVERWHELMING
PAPERWORK AND LONG PROCESSING
TIMES MEANS THAT MANY SURVIVORS
BECOME DISCOURAGED OPT OUT
ALTOGETHER. JACKSON EXPENSES
THAT HAVE NOT KEPT UP WITH
ACTUAL CROSS ADDITIONAL
PAPERWORK REQUIRED FOR URGENT
NEEDS LIKE REALLOCATION AND
LIMITS ON ELIGIBILITY FOR LOSS
OF INCOME OR SUPPORT MEANS
SURVIVORS AND THEIR LOVED ONES
OFTEN CANNOT GET THE HELP THEY
NEED FROM THE COMPENSATION
PROGRAM. IN ADDITION THE WAY THE
VICTIMS COMPENSATION PROGRAM IS
FUNDED IS ALSO A MASSIVE STAND
WHEN THE LONG TERM. INSTITUTION
FUND THAT PROVIDES THE MAJORITY
OF FUNDING FOR THE VICTIMS
COMPENSATION PROGRAM AS IN
RECENT YEARS SPENT MORE THAN IT
HAS TAKEN IN. THE STATE HAS
BACKED FEEL SOME OF THOSE LAWS
WITH GENERAL FUNDS IT HAS NOT
RETHOUGHT THE OVERALL MODEL FOR
FUNDING. CALIFORNIA MUST COMMIT
TO FULLY FUNDING THE VICTIMS
COMPENSATION PROGRAM WITH
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS. LASTLY THE
STATE MUST REPLACE. TRUMP
RECOVERY AT THE CENTER OF THE
STATE'S HUMAN STRATEGY. TRUMP
RECOVERY CENTERS REACH SURVIVORS
WHO DO NOT TYPICALLY ACCESS
TRADITIONAL VICTIM SERVICES
INCLUDING ON HOW SURVIVORS
JUSTICE INVOLVES SURVIVORS
SURVIVORS WITH CHRONIC MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS MEMBERS OF THE
IMMIGRANT AND REFUGEE GROUPS
SURVIVORS OF COLOR LGBTQ
SURVIVORS ANOTHER HISTORICALLY
MARGINALIZED GROUPS. WITH THE
SUPPORT OF THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED IN CURRENT GOVERNORS AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT THIS STATE HAS
TAKEN STEPS TO BETTER SUPPORT
FROM RECOVERY. WE CURRENTLY HAVE
EIGHTEEN FROM RECOVERY CENTERS
IN CALIFORNIA HOWEVER THOSE
EIGHTEEN DRUM RECOVERY CENTERS
ARE MAINLY CONCENTRATED IN EIGHT
OF CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES. LARGER IS OF THE STATE
DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO TRAUMA
HUMAN SERVICES. THE STATE CAN
EXPAND LOCAL CAPACITY AND GET
FROM RECOVERY SERVICES TO THOSE
WHO NEED IT MOST. THROUGH
MULTIPLE POINTS OF ENTRY. THE
PROPOSAL THAT THE SUBCOMMITTEE
IS CONSIDERING WOULD SURELY MAKE
CALIFORNIA A NATIONAL LEADER IN
SUPPORTING OUR STATE'S CRIME
SURVIVORS WE STAND READY TO
SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL. AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU MISTER
LITTLE APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK
THAT YOU DO AND- A VERY VERY
MUCH AND- YOUR INSIGHT THAT YOU
PROVIDED- NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM
JESS AND ANNIE NICHOL. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIRMAN SENATORS.
WE ARE JACKSON ANY NICKEL AND
WE'RE GOING TO BE READING OUR
TESTIMONY TOGETHER. THANK YOU
FOR HEARING ABOUT HER EXPERIENCE
. OUR SISTER POLLY KLASS WAS
KIDNAPPED FROM HER BEDROOM AND
MURDERED IN NINETEEN NINETY
THREE AT THE AGE OF TWELVE. I
WAS ALSO TWELVE YEARS OLD IN
POLAND'S KIDNAPPING AND SEX.
LOSING POLY IN THE WAY THAT WE
DID WAS INCREDIBLY DESTABILIZING
AND TRAUMATIZING. AND AS
CHILDREN TO HAVE A STRANGER
COMING TO OUR HOME AND TAKE OUR
SISTER FROM US. TORE APART THE
FABRIC OF OUR REALITY
IRREVOCABLY. AT VERY YOUNG AGES
WE ARE EXPOSED TO THE DARKEST
SIDE OF HUMANITY WHICH IS AN
EXPERIENCE THAT HAS SENT A
SHOCKWAVE THROUGH OUR LIVES TO
THIS VERY DAY. WHEN YOU'VE
EXPERIENCED THE LOSS OF A LOVED
ONE TO VIOLENCE IT TOUCHES EVERY
AREA OF YOUR LIFE. YOUR
RELATIONSHIPS OR FRIENDSHIPS.
YOUR FEELINGS ABOUT YOURSELF AND
EVERYONE AROUND YOU THIS IS NOT
JUST FOR A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME
A LOSS LIKE THIS CHANGES THE WAY
YOU VIEW THE WORLD FOREVER. WE
EXPERIENCED YEARS OF FINANCIAL
INSTABILITY AFTER TRAUMA WHICH
FORCED US TO RELOCATE
FREQUENTLY. I ATTENDED FIVE
DIFFERENT SCHOOLS IN MY FIRST
TWO YEARS OF HIGH SCHOOL BEFORE
I DROPPED OUT AND STARTED
ATTENDING COMMUNITY COLLEGE AT
THE AGE OF FIFTEEN. AND AS IS
TRUE SO MANY SURVIVORS WHO HAVE
BEEN FORCED TO LEAVE THEIR HOMES
AFTER A DEVASTATING LOSS. THAT
INSTABILITY AND LACK OF SAFETY
FOLLOWED US WHEREVER E WENT. WE
SAY ALL OF THIS TO TRY TO
EXPLAIN HOW VICTIMS OF CRIME
NEED ONGOING RESOURCES AND
SUPPORT. QALBI CB IS THE ONLY
PLACE MANY VICTIMS CAN TURN TO
TRY TO HEAL AND RECOVER FROM
TRAUMA OR TO RELOCATE OR SECURE
HOUSING FOR THEIR FAMILY. WHICH
IS WHY THE WORK IT DOES IS SO
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT. WE WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE COMPARED TO MOST OF
EXTENSIVE CRIME ANNE AND I HAVE
A GREAT DEAL OF PRIVILEGE. WE'VE
NEVER HAD TO NAVIGATE SO MANY OF
THE ELIGIBILITY BARRIERS TO
ACCESS THAT MANY OTHER VICTIMS
FACE. WHERE AS MANY VICTIMS MUST
FIGHT TO PROVE THAT HARM WAS
DONE TO THEM AND THAT THEY'RE
DESERVING OF SUPPORT. ANNE AND I
HAVE BEEN ACKNOWLEDGED AS
VICTIMS SINCE THE DAY WE LOST
QUALITY. OUR FAMILY RECEIVED AN
OUTPOURING OF SYMPATHY WHEN MANY
SURVIVORS ON THE WRIST EVEN
RECEIVE THE MOST BASIC
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF THEIR LOST
INCLUDING YOUR COMPENSATION
FUNDS. EVEN SO WE HAVE BOTH
EXPERIENCED BARRIERS IN OUR
ATTEMPTS TO SEEK OUT SUPPORT
FROM COUNTY CV. OUR DEGREE OF
PRIVILEGE HEIGHTENS OUR CONCERNS
EVEN MORE FOR THE MANY MANY
SURVIVORS WHO HAVE BEEN BLOCKED
FROM SEEKING OUT THE SUPPORT
THEY NEED AND DESERVE. BECAUSE
IF IT WAS THAT CHALLENGING FOR
US TO NAVIGATE WE IMAGINE THAT
IT'S NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE FOR FOLKS
WITH FAR LESS PRIVILEGED AND
PUBLIC VALIDATION. IN TERMS OF
OUR SPECIFIC EXPERIENCES
INTERACTING WITH THE B. C. B.
WE'LL SHARE SOME OF THE STORIES
NOW TO OFFER A CLEAR
UNDERSTANDING OF WHERE THE
CHALLENGES HAVE ARISEN FOR US.
IN RECENT YEARS I PERSONALLY
SPENT MONTHS GOING BACK AND
FORTH WITH THE VICTIM
COMPENSATION BOARD PROMPTED BY
SOME PAINFUL SITUATIONS THAT
AROSE RELATED TO POLLY'S CASE.
EVEN THOUGH I'D BEEN GIVEN A
CLAIM AS A CHILD I WAS ASKED TO
RESUBMIT MY APPLICATION MULTIPLE
TIMES AND THEN TOLD THAT MY
FORMS WERE NOT VIEWABLE FOR
REASONS RANGING FROM LAPTOP
ERRORS TO THE COUNTY FIREWALL.
USUALLY TOOK AT LEAST TWO OR
THREE FOLLOW UP EMAILS TO GET A
RESPONSE FROM PCB OVER MANY
MONTHS OF GOING BACK AND FORTH.
THE LACK OF TRAUMA SENSITIVITY
IN THE RESPONSES I RECEIVED LEFT
ME FEELING HOPELESS AND WORSEN
THE PEOPLE SITUATION I WAS AND-
AFTER SEVERAL MONTHS I LEARNED
THAT MY ORIGINAL CLAIM HAD
ALREADY ALREADY BEEN AUTHORIZED
FOR AND NUMBER COUNSELING
SESSIONS. BUT I NEVER BEEN MADE
AWARE OF THAT I WAS LEFT WAITING
UNNECESSARILY DURING ALL THOSE
MONTHS NOT SURE HOW TO MOVE MY
APPLICATION FORWARD OR IF MY
CLEAN WILL BE HONORED AT A TIME
WHEN I BADLY NEEDED SUPPORT. BY
THE TIME MY FAMILY FINALLY
MANAGED TO ECEIVE MY
REIMBURSEMENT I HAD ALREADY USED
UP ALL OF MY DESIGNATED
COUNSELING SESSIONS FOR THE
TREATMENT PLAN APPROVED BY ANY
BY B. C. B. MY OPTIONS WERE THAN
TO REAPPLY FOR FURTHER B. C. B.
SUPPORT WHICH ONLY COVERED ABOUT
HALF THE COST OF MY COUNSELING.
OR TO FIND THE FUNDS TO PAY OUT
OF POCKET AND FORWARD. IN THE
END I FOUND MY EXPERIENCE WITH
PCB SO PAINFUL AND FRUSTRATING
THAT I DECIDED NOT TO UTILIZE
THE PROGRAM AGAIN. AND IT'S
IMPORTANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THAT OPTION IS NOT AVAILABLE TO
THE SEARCH EFFORTS WERE
STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS MEET
AFTER EXPERIENCING A SEVERE
TRAUMA. THE MARKET RIGHT FOR
THEIR- IS MUCH HIGHER THAN THE
BASELINE EIGHTY ONE DOLLAR
REIMBURSEMENT AMOUNT THROUGH THE
CITY. AND HIGHLY SKILLED FROM A
THERAPIST TYPICAL COST FAR MORE.
THIS LOW REIMBURSEMENT RATE
PLACES UNDUE BURDENS ON VICTIMS
TO FIND SOMEONE WHO WILL ACCEPT
SUCH A LOW COST FOR THEIR
SERVICES. OR TO BE IN A POSITION
OF ASKING A THERAPIST TO TAKE
LESS MONEY FOR THEIR HEALING
SERVICES. PERSONALLY I HAVE HAD
TO NEGOTIATE WITH THERAPISTS TO
ACCEPT LESS MONEY TO HELP ME
HEAL WHICH IS AN AWFUL POSITION
TO BEGIN- THOSE TYPES OF
CONVERSATIONS ARE ALWAYS. HARD
AND AWKWARD BUT- WHEN I'M IN A
PLACE OF DESPERATION FOR HELP.
RECESSION ABOUT MONEY WITH THE
THERAPIST IS THE LAST THING I
WANT TO HAVE TO DO. THE ENORMOUS
GAP BETWEEN WHAT I COULD OFFER
COMPARED TO THE FEES TO
THERAPISTS TYPICALLY CHARGE.
LEFT ME WITH A SENSE OF SHAME
WHICH COMPOUNDED THE
DIFFICULTIES OF OBTAINING
SUPPORT AND NEED MY HEALING
JOURNEY HARDER- ADDITIONALLY
WHEN I WAS TRYING TO NAVIGATE
THE B. C. B. SYSTEM I WAS GIVEN
CONFLICTING INFORMATION BY
DIFFERENT REPRESENTATIVES ABOUT
TWO SEPARATE ISSUES. WHEN I
CALLED A SUPERVISOR FOR
CLARIFICATION MY COMMUNICATION
WASN'T EVER RETURNED- AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE A LOT
OF DETAILS TO BE AWARE OF IN A
SYSTEM LIKE THIS AND THAT
SOMETIMES PEOPLE CAN BE
MISINFORMED BUT THESE
CONVERSATIONS ARE HIGHER STAKES
THAN MOST. AND PEOPLE WHO ARE
ACTUALLY TALKING TO VICTIMS AND
SURVIVORS ON THE PHONE SHOULD BE
TOTALLY ON THE SAME PAGE WITH
THE MOST ACCURATE. AND UP TO
DATE INFORMATION TO HELP US
ACCESS SUPPORT- AND ALSO
SOMETHING THAT HAS WEIGHED
HEAVILY ON ME OVER THE YEARS IS
WHETHER I'D FIND OUT IF THE
PERSON WHO KILLED POLY. HAD ANY
SORT OF STATUS CHANGE WHILE IN
PRISON. LIKE DEATH OR TRANSFER
TO ANOTHER PRISON OR WHETHER
THERE IS ANY POSSIBILITY OF A RE
TRIAL. I DIDN'T KNOW UNTIL TWO
WEEKS AGO. ABOUT THE CDCR INMATE
LOCATOR. AND THAT WE COULD BE
NOTIFIED IF THERE WERE ANY
STATUS CHANGES. AND THIS SPEAKS
TO THE LACK OF RESOURCES PUT
INTO EDUCATING PEOPLE ABOUT
AVAILABLE THAT CAN SERVICES.
WHEN A PERSON HAS EXPERIENCED
THE WORST THING THAT COULD EVER
HAPPEN TO THEM. THEY SHOULDN'T
HAVE TO NAVIGATE MOUNTAINS OF
PAPERWORK OR ENGAGE WITH THE
SYSTEM THAT IS INHERENTLY
SKEPTICAL OF WHETHER THEIR PAIN
IS REAL. MOST OF US CAN ADVOCATE
FOR OURSELVES WHEN WE'RE IN THE
MIDST OF SURVIVING A LOSS LIKE
THAT. IT IS EVEN MORE PAINFUL TO
TRY TO OBTAIN SUPPORT THREE
SYSTEM THAT VIEWS ARE HEARTBREAK
WITH SUSPICION. TOO OFTEN THESE
BARRIERS BECOMING RE
TRAUMATIZING EXPERIENCE THAT
TEACHES VICTIMS NOT TO SEEK OUT
SUPPORT IN THE FIRST PLACE. MY
EXPERIENCE WITH PCB FELT LIKE A
BATTLING IT TO FIGHT ON TOP OF
ALL THE OTHER BATTLE SURVIVORS
MUST INTO OUR DAILY TO REBUILD
THEIR LIVES. AFTER THOSE MONTHS
OF GOING BACK AND FORTH WITH
COUNTY CITY. DISTINCTLY FELT BUT
THE SYSTEM THAT WAS DESIGNED
WITH GREATER EMPHASIS ON
PREVENTING FUNDS FROM BEING
GIVEN TO SOMEONE IT DEEMS
UNDESERVING. RATHER THAN A
SYSTEM FUNDAMENTALLY BUILT TO
SUPPORT THE IMMEDIATE AND LONG
TERM NEEDS OF VICTIMS. NOT ONLY
DOES THIS WORK AGAINST THE
PEOPLE COUNTY CD WAS CREATED TO
SUPPORT THEIR COMPROMISES COULD
PUBLIC SAFETY I PUT. ALL WHO
HAVE EXPERIENCED A DEATH IN LOSS
INTO EVEN MORE DESPERATE
CIRCUMSTANCES. TRAUMA FROM
VIOLENCE IS A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY IN THIS COUNTRY AND-
VICTIMS COMPENSATION IS ONE OF
THE FEW PROGRAMS THAT EXIST TO
ADDRESS IT. AS THE VICTIMS OF
SUCH A HIGH PROFILE CASE TO JESS
AND I ARE FORTUNATE TO HAVE
NETWORKS OF SUPPORT THAT MOST
SURVIVORS DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO.
WE WANT TO DO EVERYTHING IN OUR
POWER TO ENSURE THAT OUR FELLOW
SURVIVORS HAVE ALL THE HELP YOU
NEED BECAUSE THERE IS NO.
GREATER FORCE FOR SAFETY IN THIS
COUNTRY AND THE ABILITY TO HEAL
RECOVER. FROM TRAUMA. THANK YOU
. THANK YOU BOTH SO UP VERY MUCH
AND THANK YOU AT THANK YOU
JESSON ANNIE. REALLY APPRECIATE
YOU TAKING THE TIME. OUT NOT
ONLY SHARE WHAT YOUR EXPERIENCES
HAVE BEEN- BUT I THINK MORE
IMPORTANTLY IS HOW YOU BECOME
ADVOCATES YOURSELF. INSPIRED OF
GOING THROUGH ALL OF THIS-
PAINFUL- PAINFUL MEMORIES- AT
THIS POINT DOUG MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
NO I JUST YOU KNOW THANKS AGAIN
TO THE WITNESSES. THAT IS
IMPRESSIVE RETURN TRASH UNIT
ADVOCACY SO WE WERE FORTUNATE TO
HAVE THAT. YOU WORKING I JUST
HAVE ONE- QUESTION ON THE- ON
ONE PROGRAM THE IMMEDIATE
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM- WHAT ARE THE
OUTCOMES THAT WE COULD UP
MEASURE TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PROGRAM IS WORKING AS WE WOULD
LIKE IT TO WORK. CENTENO WHO
FEELS BEST. TO ANSWER THAT. TAKE
A CONTRACT. ATTEMPT TO- AND
SPEAK TO THIS A QUESTION OF FROM
THE PERSPECTIVE OF- SOMETHING
THAT WE- TRIED AS AN
ORGANIZATIONS TO KIND OF STEP IN
THE GAP FOR- VICTIMS AS ME-
GAVE- RESOURCES TO ORGANIZATIONS
ON THE GROUND WHO PROVIDED
SERVICES FOR- SURVIVORS IN NEED
TO HELP THEM- MAKE IT THROUGH
THOSE TOUGH TIMES AND- THOSE
RESOURCES. FROM US WERE
UNRESTRICTED AND I THINK YOU
KNOW THIS IS REALLY SPEAKS TO ME
THE IMPORTANCE OF CAL BCV. WHICH
IS TO STAND IN THE GAP IN BE A
RESOURCE FOR- FOR VICTIMS OF IN
THERE- OFTEN DARKEST HOURS- YOU
KNOW WHEN I LISTEN TO JAZZ IN
ANY YOU KNOW I SEE. IN A ROOM
WHY THIS THIS IS SO CRUCIALLY
IMPORTANT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH JESSEN ANY ANY LAST.
COMMENTS THAT YOU WANT TO SHARE
WITH US. THANK YOU FOR HEARING
US TODAY. GREAT OKAY- WELL
CERTAINLY I KNOW THAT'S OF HIGH
IMPORTANCE FOR US WE APPRECIATE
YOUR- YOUR COMMENTS. AND ALSO I
THINK FOR ME AFTER HEARING BOTH
JUST OF AN ANTI THAT UP THIS IS
WHAT OF CRIME SURVIVORS GO
THROUGH IS NOT SOMETHING THAT
YOU CAN SAY IN A PARTICULAR TIME
PERIOD AFTER THAT YOU DON'T HAVE
TO WORRY ABOUT IT ANYMORE NO
MORE ISSUES THIS OBVIOUSLY
SOMETHING THAT COLD GO ON
THROUGHOUT YOUR LIFETIME SO I
THINK WE NEED TO KEEP THAT. IN
MIND AS WE MOVE FORWARD
CERTAINLY WILL DO ALL THAT WE
CAN TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
RESOURCES ARE THERE AND THAT THE
RESOURCES ARE BEING. PROVIDED IN
THE MOST SENSITIVE WAY POSSIBLE
AND THE MOST EFFECTIVE WAY
POSSIBLE SO AGAIN- GREATLY
APPRECIATE MISTER LITTLE AND
JUSTIN AND THE NICKEL THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU. AND THANK
YOU OUR FINAL ISSUE SIX OUR
REGIONAL PUBLIC SAFETY
COLLABORATIVE- WE'RE GOING TO
START OUT WITH- THE L. A. O. AND
I THINK THAT'S MISS PETERS. I
DON'T CARE JUST GET PETERS I CAN
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AND THE SENATE IS
CONSIDERING A PROPOSAL TO EXPAND
A PILOT REGIONAL PUBLIC SAFETY
COLLABORATIVE PROGRAM AND THIS
STATE HAS PREVIOUSLY AND IS
CURRENTLY FUNDING ON THE NORTH
COUNTY NORTH OF ORANGE COUNTY
COLLABORATIVE- WHICH INCLUDES
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS-
AND IF YOU ADDRESS VARIOUS
ISSUES INCLUDING HOUSING YEARS.
USING VIOLENCE AND HOSTING
PERSPIRATION RE ENTRY ON THIS
PROGRAM IS FUNDED BY THE STATE
BEGINNING IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO
EIGHTEEN BUDGET ARM WITH TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WAS
AVAILABLE OVER A FOUR YEAR
PERIOD AND THEN WHEN THAT
FUNDING EXPIRED THAT CURRENT
YEAR BUT- TWEET EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS ON A ONE TIME BASIS. SO
THAT FUNDING. WOULD EXPIRE AT
THE END OF. YEAR AND I BELIEVE
YOU HAVE SINCE BEEN. ON THE FOR
AXLE TO PROVIDE MORE DETAIL THE
PROPOSED. ACTUALLY NO YEAH. I'M
HERE MA'AM SHARE WELL- JUST JUST
ONE SECOND- HOW ARE WE GONNA DO
THIS DO WE PROCEED EVIL WITHOUT
SEEING THE BILL WITNESSES. WE
CAN'T SUE THE WHIMS OF THE
PUBLIC SOONER. OKAY. IF YOU'LL
EXCUSE US ON JUST ONE MINUTE
WE'RE TRYING TO CORRECT SOME.
TECHNOLOGY. JUDGE YOUR CONSUME
ADDED YOU KNOW THIS IS YOUR OF
VISUALIZATION. WELL SOMETIMES
SOMETIMES YEAR AS THE MATER WE I
HAVEN'T SEEN THE LAST RECESSION
. YES GUYS YOU GUYS NOT AS GOOD
. THANK W. SHOW OKAY. BUT THE
PUBLIC SNATCHING. OKAY BUT THE
WORDS THAT'S YEAH MOST IMPORTANT
OKAY WE WILL SEE HOPEFULLY WE
CAN GET IT FIXED OF. SORRY IN
THE MIDDLE OF ALL OF THIS. THIS
PETERS YOU HAVE NOT FINISHED
RIGHT YOU WERE. DID YOU MANAGER
WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO REENTER
DESPITE M. AND I BELIEVE YOU
HAVE SOME SPEAKERS HERE TO GO
INTO MORE DETAIL BUT IT'S JUST
AS A BRIEF RECAP AND THIS STATE
HAS PROVIDED SOME ONE TIME
FUNDING- FOR THIS NORTH AMHERST
COUNTY COLLABORATIVE WHICH IS A
COLLABORATIVE GROUP BETWEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND- AND NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS TO ADDRESS A
VARIETY OF ISSUES INCLUDING
HOUSING AND YOUTH VIOLENCE AND
I'M POSTING PERSPIRATION RE
ENTRY PROGRAMS- IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN THE STATE
PROVIDE TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS.
ONE TIME THAT WAS AVAILABLE OVER
. WHEN THE- EXPIRED I IN THE CAR
YEAR- THE BY INCLUDES SEVEN
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS ON A ONE
TIME BASIS ON THE END SO THAT
THAT ONE TIME FUNDING WILL
EXPIRE AT THE END OF THIS
CURRENT BUDGET YEAR AND SO I
BELIEVE YOU HAVE SPEAKERS ON TO
SPEAK TO SOME OF THAT THE MERITS
AS POSSIBLE CONTINUING THIS
PROGRAM I'M IN THE BUDGET YEAR
OR BEYOND. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YES WE WILL MOVE ON NOW TO- OUR
WITNESSES SU ELIZABETH CARING
FROM THE CITY OF STAUNTON.
MORNING INSURANCE SENATORS- MY
NAME IS C. K. AND I AM WITH THE
CITY SENSE AND BUT ON SPECIAL
ASSIGNMENT FOR THE NORTH ORANGE
COUNTY PUBLIC SAFETY
COLLABORATIVE- YES WE THE KEY
WORD HERE IS THAT IT WAS A PILOT
FOUR YEARS AGO. AND THUS FAR-
ONE OF THE FOUNDATIONAL PRIMARY
FOUNDATIONAL ACTIVITIES THAT WE
SET FORTH WAS ACCOUNTABILITY
WITH RESULTS. SO WE STARTED WITH
DATA IN THE AREA OF HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS. WE WENT OUT AND
SOUGHT OUT EIGHT FINING REGISTRY
REAL HOMELESS CENSUS BACK IN
SPRING OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN. AND
WE COUNTED ONE THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED THIRTY SEVEN PEOPLE HERE
NORTH ORANGE COUNTY. AND ONE
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED TWENTY
FOUR OF THEM PROVIDED US WITH
THEIR PERSONAL DEMOGRAPHIC NAMES
AND INFORMATION AND SINCE THEN
WE HAVE THE BALLING THEM OVER
SIX HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE HAVE BEEN
PERMANENTLY HOUSE. WITH FIVE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY TWENTY FOUR I
ENGAGE IN CASE MANAGEMENT
SERVICES. HE WENT ON WITH THE
STATE AT TWO HUNDRED ON A
TECHNOLOGY TOOL I'LL WE
DISCOVERED A SOFTWARE COMPANY
CALLED OUT EACH FOR IT. WHERE IS
A SINGULAR PLATFORM WITH A
UNIFIED RESPONSIBILITY OF IT
RESPONDING TO CALLS FOR SERVICES
RELATED TO HOMELESSNESS AND-
MENTAL ILLNESS. AND SUBSTANCE
USE THAT'S IN OUR STREETS. AND
SO WITH THIS OP- THEY ADDED
FEATURES LIKE A BAD SELTZER
RESERVATIONS SO WITH THE TAP OF
ONE. FEATURE ON YOUR PHONE- YOU
CAN RESERVE. AT ONE OF OUR THREE
NAVIGATION CENTERS- IN ADDITION
TO. BE THAT WAS FEINSTEIN THAT
BACHELOR RESERVATION BY THE WAY
IS TEN MINUTES SO YOU KNOW THAT
YOU HAVE A BAD ESPECIALLY IF YOU
HAVE A PERSON ON THE STREET WHO. WAS WILLING TO TAKE A SHELTER.
I ON TOP THAT WE HAVE ADDED A
FEATURE WHERE IT YOU'RE OF THE-
A VETERAN ORGAN CALLED L. L. IS
NOTED. AND THEIR OWN RESOURCE
AND SPECIALIST OUT AND WORK
WITHIN. WHO EXPERIENCED HOMELESS
- ONE OF THE THINGS ABOUT THIS
PILOT IS IT THAT THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN REPLICATE
ELSEWHERE SO THEY GOING TO BEACH
THE CITY REALLY GOING TO BEACH
THE WHICH- AS- CITY DOWN IN
SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY. HAVE TAKEN
ON THEIR OWN OUT OF REACH FOR IT
AND- BECAUSE THEY HAVE A
SHELTER. AND THEY ARE ROBUSTLY
USING- OUT RESTRICTS YOU GET
THESE FOLKS WITH RESOURCES AND
HOUSING AS WELL AS SELTZER- EN
ELEMENTARY JUST ON TO- I'M
TAKING A COMPONENT OF OUR MODEL
AND AGAIN. OUTRAGE WORKERS
WORKING ON ON THIS APP. MORE
IMPORTANTLY I AFTER FOR YEARS-
WE HAD AND THE IS THE NUMBER
THAT GOING TO PROVIDE. WE HAD
OVER FIFTY ONE COMMUNITY BASED
ON. WITH OVER THREE HUNDRED FOR
ONE PROJECT- IN THE AREAS OF
YOUTH VIOLENCE PREVENTION
INTERVENTION- HOMELESS OUTREACH
AND ENGAGEMENT AS WELL AS
REENTRY SERVICES. AT THE
CULMINATION OF THAT IN THIS
CURRENT YEAR WITH THE SEVEN
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IS
THE HOPE CENTER AND THEN A HALF
CHIEF DOWN HERE WHO'S GOING TO
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE HELP
CENTER. GREAT MORNING THAT
OCCURRED ONE OF THE SENATORS-
BUT DILIGENTLY CITY FORT AND
ALSO THE CHAIR. OF THE
COLLABORATIVE THIS YEAR- SO ASK
YOU INDICATED. WE HAVE BEEN
FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO HAVE SUPPORT
OF THE STATE THE LAST FOUR NOW
FIVE YEARS. AND AS WE HAVE
NAVIGATED THROUGH FUNDING
CYCLES. THE CITIES THAT
PARTICIPATED THIS ALL ELEVEN OF
US NOW- HAVE TRIED TO LEVERAGE
OUR EXISTING RESOURCES IN A MORE
REGIONAL WAY. SO THAT WE CAN
WHAT WE CALL PROVIDE THE RIGHT
SERVICE RIGHT NOW. TO THOSE
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND
THAT'S WHERE THE CONCEPT OF THE
HOPE CENTER WHICH STANDS FOR.
ALMOST OUR REGION CORRECTIVE
ENGAGEMENT. OR NOT. THE LOCATION
HERE IN THE CITY OF FORT AND
WHERE ALL THE SERVICE PROVIDERS
WHO ARE OPERATING IN OUR AREAS
IN OUR CITIES. WILL CALM DOWN
PROVIDE SYNERGISTIC SERVICES TO
OUR HOMELESS POPULATION. ODDS TO
MENTION SOME OF OUR PARTNERS
WERE SIGNED ON P. O. L. A. SO WE
CAN. MAKE SURE WE TOUCH OUR
VETERANS OF THE WAY THAT. MOST
AFFECTED. I ALSO HAVE HAD
ENCOURAGING. WITH CAL. WAS THE
MATTER MISS- FOR THE COUNTY OF
TO BE PARTING US. WE ARE GOING
TO LAUNCH A COMMUNITY PARAMEDIC
PRO IS A REALLY TO THAT. AND OF
THIS ENERGY THAT BEEN CREE
AROUND THESE THREE FOCUS AREAS
IS REALLY A DIRECT RESULT OF.
THE FOR THE FOURTH OUT OF THE
STATE TO HELP US LAUNCH THESE
PROJECTS. OUR ABILITY TO WORK
WITH THE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. ALL OF WHICH
RECEIVE 60% OF THE FUNDING THAT
WE RECEIVE FROM THE STATE ONLY
40% GOES BACK TO THE OPERATIONS
OF THE CITY. BECAUSE WE REALIZE
WE NEED TO GET THE RIGHT
RESOURCES RIGHT NOW TO THE RIGHT
PEOPLE AND- WE ARE. PLEASED BY
THE THOUGHT THAT THIS CONTINUE
WE'RE HOPING AND ARE SUPPORTED
OF COURSE OF THE CONTINUANCE OF
THIS. AND I THINK WE'RE SEEING
REAL RESULTS HERE AND THE OF THE
OF OUR ABILITY TO DUPLICATE
THESE IN AREAS LIKE SAN
FRANCISCO. AND ALL THE OTHER
AREAS THAT YOU MENTIONED-
THROUGH THE USE OF OUR
TECHNOLOGY TOOL I THINK HE IS
GETTING US BETTER OUTCOMES FOR
THOSE. EXPERIENCING HOT DISTROS
WHO. AS THE VIOLENCE THAT WE CAN
GET TO A MENTOR BEFORE THEY GET
THERE. THERE ARE ACTUALLY TWO
ADDITIONAL- HIGHLIGHTS OF OUR
COLLABORATIVE WHICH IS ONE- I
GOING AGAIN GOING BACK TO
ACCOUNTABILITY WITH RESULTS- WE
CONTRACTED WITH CAL STATE
FULLERTON WITH THEIR SOCIAL
SCIENCE RESEARCH CENTER AND THEY
HAVE BEEN INDEPENDENTLY
REVIEWING AND EVALUATING AND US.
FOR THE LAST FOUR AND A HALF
YEARS AND ON OUR WEBSITE TWO
PURPOSES FOR OUR WEBSITE SO THAT
OTHERS COULD SEE FROM OTHER RE-
REPLICATE. SOME OF THE
COMPONENTS OF OUR MODEL AND THEN
ALSO. RFP PROCESS OF- GETTING
FUNDING 260% THAT SHE'S DONE I
SPOKE NEVADA IT IS 60% WHILE IT
IS TRUE WE PROVIDED ACTUALLY
MORE THAN 60% BECAUSE WE HAD
THESE ASKING BUILDING WORKSHOPS.
AND WHAT THEY ARE IS A WORKSHOPS
FOR OUR CEOS WE'VE HAD CBO SAID
LITERALLY I WORKED OUT OF THE
GARAGES AND THE- NATIONALS. US
SO HAVE SOMEBODY LIKE WE THREE
EIGHT TWO BOYS AND CLUB. OF AND
THE LOCAL. OR BIG BROTHERS BIG
SISTERS. AT LEAST COMPASSIONATE
BUILDING WORKSHOPSWAS FOR
REALLY ONE PURPOSE THAT AT THE
END OF FOUR YEARS OR FIVE YEARS
THAT THEY'RE MUCH MORE BOYS AS
AN ORGANIZATION ORGANIZATION FOR
CAPACITY. TO RECEIVE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING OUTSIDE OF THE
COLLABORATIVE. SO WE'VE HAD
GRANT MKING MARKETING- FOR
DEVELOPMENT STRATEGIC VISIONING.
WHAT THAT REALLY WALKING THE
DOCUMENT THAT REALLY WAS THE
ARTICLE CO COLLABORATION WHICH
IS A SYMPOSIUM. HELD DURING THE
PANDEMIC IT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
IN PERSON ALTHOUGH WE DID YES DO
AND WE HAD OUR TAYLOR AND
NATIONAL PHILANTHROPIC LEADER
WHO CAME OUT AND TALKED ABOUT
COLLABORATION. AND WHAT HE
ADDRESSED U. S. AS HE WAS-STUDYING THIS COLLABORATIVE
MODEL WAS THAT. INDICATOR THAT
WE- AND STARTED A NEW THAT. IN
CHARGE. AND THAT NEW VALUE IS
NOT WORN OUT OF DESPERATION BUT
I'D OF INNOVATION TO COLLABORATE
TOGETHER SO THAT WE BUILD THIS
BRIDGE BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND OURCEOS- CEOS THAT DIDN'T
EVEN KNOW THAT THEY EXISTED AND
WORK TOGETHER. SO WE HAVE AN
ORGANIZATION CALLED CHRIS LISTS
IT'S LARGELY OUT OF LA BUT THEY
CAME INTO ORANGE COUNTY THEY
PROVIDE- EMPLOYMENT SERVICES
ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE THAT ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. WELL
CHRYSALIS- PARTNERED WITH THE
BOYS AND GIRLS CLUB BECAUSE WE
HAVE A LARGE A LARGE AMOUNT OF
MEMBERS OF THOSE CLASSES THIS
FAMILIES ARE UNDEREMPLOYED. AND
CRYSTALLISED PARTNERED WITH OUR
BOYS AND GIRLS CLUB WHICH IS THE
BIG SEVEN BECAUSE THERE ARE SOME
CLUBS. AND THEY STARTED WORKING
THE WITH THE FAMILIES THAT
INDICATED THAT THEY WANT TO
IMPLEMENT BETTER THAN WHAT THEY
HAVE NOW THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
WE IT WAS UNINTENDED- BUT
THROUGH THESE COLLABORATIVE
WORKSHOPS- PARTNERSHIPS. FORMS
WE THAT WE HAVE INTERNET ANYONE
MIGHT HAVE. THANK YOU. THANK
THANK YOU SO MUCH. IT'S GREAT TO
HEAR ABOUT A- POSITIVE PROGRAM
THAT'S WORKING- AND DON'T REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT. I KNOW SIR
NEWMAN VERY A PROUD IN THE
EXCITED- IF I COULD JUST ASK ONE
QUESTION- CHIEF DONE- CAN YOU
DESCRIBE THE- DEPARTMENT'S.
INTERACTIONS WITH THE ON THE
HOUSE TO POPULATION HOW. YOU
KNOW HAS THAT CHANGED- WHAT WHAT
IS THAT RELATIONSHIP. I KNOW
THAT SURE ISN'T A DIFFICULT
PLACE FOR OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT.
YES MA'AM AND I THINK- BUT THE
BEAUTY OF THIS COLLABORATIVE IS
THAT YOU'RE ASKING ME ABOUT MY
DEPARTMENT BUT IT REALLY IS THE
CONSENSUS ACROSS ELEVEN CITIES
HERE IN THE NORTH SO ALL ELEVEN
POLICE AGENCIES. HAVE KIND OF
SHIFTED THE MINDSET OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT INTO- SERVICES FIRST
ENFORCEMENT LAST I THINK ALL OF
US HERE ESPECIALLY IN THE
NORTHWESTERN AREA I UNDERSTAND
FULLY THAT WE'RE NOT GOING TO
ARREST OUR WAY OUT OF ALMOST IS
THE ISSUE. AND SO WHAT WE DO IS
WE TAKE PASSIONATE- RELATIONSHIP
BUILDING APPROACH AND WE BUILD A
REPORT WITH THE MOST MEMBERS IN
ARCADIA EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS TO GET THE BEST
OUTCOME FOR THEM BECAUSE THAT'S
TRULY WHERE SUCCESS LIES NOT IN
IN IN INCARCERATION OR EVEN
CITATION. AND PUTTING SOMEONE
INTO THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
AND SO BUT THE POSTURE THAT WE
TAKE YEARS SERVICES FIRST
ENFORCEMENT LAST AND THAT THAT'S
WHY THAT I'LL REACH FOR TOOLS
BEEN SO IMPORTANT FOR US
BECAUSE- IT GIVES THAT PERSON
YEAH INDIVIDUAL THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH BECAUSE WHAT WE'VE
FOUND THROUGH OUR PROCESS OF THE
LAST FIVE YEARS IS THAT. THE
EXPERIENCING HOMES JUST OUR
INDIVIDUAL AND HOW THEY GOT
THERE AN INDIVIDUAL OUT HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO GET OUT OF
THERE AND SO IF AN OFFICER WHO'S
NEVER. THIS PARTICULAR
INDIVIDUAL BEFORE COULD HAVE
THEIR STORY IN FRONT OF THEM IT
SERVE THE ABILITY FOR THEM TO
BRIDGE THAT REPORT GAP A LOT
QUICKER OUR FIRST ENCOUNTER THIS
IS IT THE CARD AND SO I THINK
WHEN I WHEN I TALK ABOUT WHAT WE
DO HERE IN NORTH ORANGE COUNTY.
IS FOCUS ON THAT FIRST OF COURSE
ENFORCED IS A TWO THAT WE CAN
EMPLOY. BUT WE WANT TO BRING
THOSE RESOURCES TO BEAR THAT'S
GOING TO GET THAT PERSON TO A
BETTER PLACE INTO A PLACE WHERE
THEY WANT TO BE. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR NEWMAN- I
HAPPEN HAVE SOME THOUGHTS ON
THIS. SO IT IS WONDERFUL TO SEE
I'M BY DIE KUNST I'M NOT SURE WE
CAN SEE THAT THE CHIEF AND- MISS
CAN'T. I AM VERY PROUD OF THIS
FIVE YEAR EFFORT I AND I'M I'M
PROUD ON YOUR BEHALF AND EYES
YES ANYBODY KNOWS WHO KNOWS I'M
JUST SMART ENOUGH TO KNOW A GOOD
IDEA. WHEN I HEAR IT ABOUT FIVE
YEARS AGO OF A GROUP OF CITY
MANAGER'S CHIEFS CAME. TO MY
OFFICE IN THE THEY HAD AN IDEA
THEY'D BE AND IT WAS BASED ON
OBSERVATION THE OBSERVATION WAS
THAT. THE EFFORTS AT LEAST
LOCALLY RUN HOMELESSNESS HAD
DEFIED- BE SORT OF MUNICIPAL
EFFORTS RIGHT THAT THAT CITY
LEVELED TO THE PROBLEM IS TOO
BIG- TO ADDRESS KIND OF ON A
CITY BY CITY BASIS AND AT THE
STATE LEVEL- TOP DOWN SOLUTIONS
DIDN'T REALLY WORK AND SO THE
IDEA WAS WHAT IF WE COULD WE
COULD. WE COULD CREATE. A
REGIONAL APPROACH TO THAT USED
AS ITS BASIS YOU KNOW THE RIGHT
SIZE. UNIT AND THAT THAT STARTED
AS EIGHT CITIES IS NOW ELEVEN.
AND IT- VERY GRATEFUL TO SU
GANG- TO CHIEF CORPORATION IS IT
WHEN PARK JUST RETIRED- FOR
THEIR LEADERSHIP IN AL CHIEF
DONE FOR ASSUMING. WE SHOULD
ROLL. OUT OF BED BUT AS MISS
KING MENTIONED. YOU KNOW
INNOVATIONS HERE WERE. THE THIS
COLLAB. EFFORT LED TO INCREASE
COORDINATION- BETTER ALIGNMENT
BETTER ACCOUNTABILITY- THAT
RESULTED IN A LIKE CAPACITY
BUILDING BUT ALSO INNOVATION-
AND SO NO NO SMALL THING. TO
HAVE. CREATED THIS MOBILE
PLATFORM WHICH IS SOLVING A VERY
REAL PROBLEM EVERY SINGLE CITY
HAS THE SAME PROBLEM ABOUT.
CONNECTING ON HOUSE PEOPLE TO
BEDS IN A WAY THAT ACTUALLY GETS
THEM INTO. A SAFE PLACE AND MOVE
THEM FORWARD- AND SO YOU KNOW I
HAVE A COMPANION BILL. SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTEEN. WHICH WOULD.
YOU KNOW KIND OF-
INSTITUTIONALIZED JUST BROKE. IT
BUT IT'S THE IDEA IS THIS IS A
MODEL WHICH IS VERY WORTHY OF
REPLICATION. AND FURTHER
INNOVATION- AND- YOU KNOW WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE AMOUNTS OF MONEY
THE MAN SPENT ON ON
HOMELESSNESS- OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS IT'S IN THE
BILLIONS AND SO WHAT WHAT WE'RE
SAYING HERE IS NORMALLY A- VERY
GOOD RETURN. ON INVESTMENT. BUT
AGAIN YOU KNOW A REALLY SOLID
BASIS FOR IT FOR ENHANCING
COLLABORATION AND ACTUALLY
APPLYING THAT TO OTHER SYSTEMS.
UP SO YOU KNOW BROUGH HOPEFUL-
THAT WE CAN WE CAN INCLUDE THIS
IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET- AND AGAIN
VERY GRATEFUL. TO EVERYBODY. IN
MY REGION WHO HAS WORKED ON
THIS. AGAIN I I'VE HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF WATCHING THIS
INVOLVES- AND IT IS SPEND
IMMENSELY GRATIFYING ENCOURAGING
TO DO SO. THANK YOU. WHAT CAN
ACTUALLY TO EVERYONE FOR THE
PROGRESS IF YOU'VE MADE- WITH.
ANY ANY OF SENATOR CRITICIZING
IN- ANY OF ANY FINAL WERE EITHER
- CHIEF ARE IS SCANNING. I THINK
WOULD JUST SAY WORK THREE THE
STATE FOR BARBECUE THUS FAR WE
HAVE REALLY WORKED OVER THE LAST
FIVE YEARS TO BE GOOD STEWARDS
OF WHAT YOU HAVE DONE AND FOR US
AND- WE HOPE TO CONTINUE THAT
AND WORK WITH OTHERS TO
REPLICATE THIS THROUGHOUT THE
CITY CALIFORNIA'S FEEL LIKE WE
HAVE A WINNING MODELS HERE. WHEN
GREAT AT ALSO AND JUST THAT AND
- WE WOULD LIKE TO INVITE YOU TO
THE HOPE CENTER WILL BE OPEN.
AND PLEASE COME ON DOWN YOU'RE
NOT TOO FAR FROM US SACRAMENTO
IS JUST A FLIGHT AWAY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THE NVITATION-
WONDERFUL OKAY WELL- WE WILL
FIND OUT WE'VE REACHED THE END
OF THESE ITEMS ON THE AGENDA-
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO. OH I'M
SORRY YES WE SKIP THAT- I WOULD
LIKE TO MOVE ON NOW TO.
ESTABLISHING A QUORUM SO A
DOCTOR BACK BILL WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL ROLE. SENATOR DORADO
HERE SENATOR PRESENT SENATOR
GROW. SENATOR CORTEZ IN SENATOR
CORTEZ THE PRESIDENT SENATOR
NEWMAN. SENATOR NEWMAN PRESENTS
A QUORUM HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE MOVING
ON ARE NOW TO ANYONE WANTING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT REGARDING
ANY OF THE ITEMS ON THE AGENDA
THE A PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS
877-226-8163 AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS SEVEN SIX TWO TWO FOUR SIX
TWO- DUE TO THE LENGTH OF THE
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. WERE ESTABLISHING OF
LIMITATION OF PLEASE MAXIMUM ONE
MINUTE A PER. PUBLICWE'RE GOING
TO BEGIN HERE- IN THE ROOM IF
THERE ARE ANY. IN PERSON
WITNESSES PLEASE COME RIGHT UP
AND- YOU'RE WELCOME THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING DAN AYKROYD ARM ON
BEHALF OF THAT DEBT FREE JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA COALITION IN SUPPORT
OF ISSUE NUMBER FIVE- WANTING TO
HIGHLIGHT THE NEED TO STABILIZE
THE STATE'S RESTITUTION FUND BUT
ALSO NEED AND RELIANCE ON
CRIMINAL FINES AND FEES TO
PROVIDE COMPENSATION TO
SURVIVORS IN THE STATE. THANKS
MUCH THANK YOU FOR COMING.
ANYONE ELSE IN PERSON. NO SEEN
NONE WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
OUR- COLEEN INSO MODERATOR IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WANTING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE
TELECONFERENCE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT ON
TODAY'S CALL YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AT THE END ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU CAN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT ON TODAY'S CALL ONE IN
THE. ONE FOURTEEN NEARLY IS OPEN
PLEASE GO. HELLO MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS NO WAY OUT AUTUMN HELLO
WILL. WITHIN SPENDING. WORKS
EIGHT FIVE LEGAL AID OR- WE ARE
. THE FUNDING FOR THE WAY
OAKLAND ACT ONE A WEEK IN THE
FOR OF ISSUE ONE THE LEGAL PAPER
PORTANTINO AND THE FUNDS. CAN WE
MADE IT COMMENT AND ALL A LINE
COMMON WITH THE LEGAL OF THREE.
THANK YOU VERY FOR YOUR- THANK
YOU FOR CALLING PRECIADO. OF
MODERN APPROXIMATELY. HOW MANY
DO WE HAVE AN Q. SACRAMENTO.
ELEVEN OKAY PLEASE PROCEED. NINE
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NOT HAVE TO
MINISTER ON BEHALF OF BURKE AT
THE CALIFORNIA IN THE
PROSECUTOR'S A LINE CALIFORNIA
ON ITEM NUMBER FIVE. EXPRESSING
OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR EXPANDING
SYSTEMS TO VICTIMS. PROVIDING
ASSISTANCE PEOPLE WHO EXPERIENCE
TRAUMA AND HELPING THEM HEAL
FROM THEIR TRAUMA IS ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT THINGS WE CAN DO
TO IMPROVE PUBLIC SAFETY HURT
PEOPLE HURT PEOPLE WE AT THE
STATE NEEDS TO BETTER TO CARE
FOR PEOPLE. TO MAKE CALIFORNIA
BETTER AND SAFER FOR ALL THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR CALLING NEXT
PLEASE. NINE TWELVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CRENELLATED WITH THE
CHILD CARE LESS THAN ANYTHING ON
THE WAITER. IT'S CARE LAW AND WE
ARE WE CALLED BUT IF THE SHOE
ONE TO INCREASE. THE FUNDING FOR
THE. EIGHTY MUCH THANK YOU FOR
NEXT. ONE FORTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS SARAH MAKE ME
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF AND SHE
ACTED A MEMBER OF THAT REJECTED
CALIFORNIA COALITION. CALLING
SUPPORTER OF AGENDA ISSUE ITEM
FIVE THE STABILIZE THE STATE
RESTITUTION FINE AND TO AND
RELIANCE ON CRIMINAL MINDS THE
FEES TO PROVIDE COMPENSATION FOR
CALIFORNIANS TO BUY MEAT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR CALLING NEXT
PLEASE. LINE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THERE
ON THAT FROM MOST LEGISLATIVE
COUNCIL WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATE I
WE ARE AMONG THE STATE ONE
HUNDRED LEGAL SERVICES PROVIDER
THAT BENEFIT FROM LEGAL AID
FUNDING IN THE JUDICIAL BRANCH
BUDGET. THOUGH WITH REGARD TO
ISSUE ONE WE WISH TO VOICE OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE BUDGET REQUEST
MADE BY THE LEGAL AID
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA.
PACIFIC WE STRONGLY SUPPORT OUT
ALLOCATING AN ADDITIONAL THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO THE EQUAL
ACCESS FUND THE COURT STATE
LEGAL AID FUNDING SOURCE FOR
SERVICES PROVIDERS TO KEEP
FUNDING LEVEL WITH LAST YEAR'S-
INVESTMENT OF SEVENTY MILLION-
EVEN IF EQUAL ACCESS FUND
REMAINS LEVEL YEAH THAT THE-
SERVICES REMAINS ENORMOUS.
PARTICULARLY FOR EVICTION
DEFENSE WE ALSO REQUEST A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION FOR
HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION SERVICES
INCLUDING STATE WHITE PEOPLE
CONTENT AND EDUCATION FOR
VULNERABLE TENANTS. LAST WEEK IN
RECOGNITION OF THE GROWING NEED
WE REQUESTED A ONE TIME
ALLOCATION OF FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR A MULTI YEAR GRANTS
FOR CONSUMER DEBT LEGAL
SERVICES. THANK YOU FOR
CONTINUING TO INVEST IN LEGAL
AID WHICH ALLOWS NONPROFIT LEGAL
SERVICES PROVIDERS LIKE PUBLIC
ADVOCATE TO HELP SERVE OUR
STATE'S MOST VULNERABLE UNITS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT PLEASE. ONE FORTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE AHEAD.
HI THIS IS MY VALLEY I'LL BE OUT
OF THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT AND
BY. WE'RE YOU CAN TRY ORDER
ISSUE ITEM ONE FOR AND FIVE. TO
CREATE A TIME I'LL GRANT
PROGRAMS BETWEEN BASED
ORGANIZATION TO PROVIDE THE
CASUAL IN HIS VICTIMS. IN
ADDITION THAT WE ARE- FONG
ORDERED THAT THEY CAN COMPENSATE
PROP TO RUNNING COMPETITION.
HELLO WORD OF MOUTH AND
STREAMLINING YEAH PROCESS RIGHT
THE BEEN MORE EVEN THOUGH
DOCTORS BUT- FOR OFTEN FROM OR
HE FUND FOR THE AID IN THE ENTRY
THAT ACT ONE AND LAST. PARTNER
ALSO- OF FEAR- WOULD BE FOR A
FIFTEEN YEAR AND ON GOING ON FOR
SEXUAL DOMESTIC VIOLENCE EVENT
PROGRAMS ADMINISTERED. CAL YES
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT PLEASE. WHEN THREE YOUR
LONG IS OPEN PLEASE GO. MORNING
THE CARD FOR THE. FOR EXAMPLE
THE WHOLE. IN FACT I'M GOING TO
TRY HE JOHN VERY VERY OFTEN.
THANK GOODNESS BECAUSE HE- THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR NEXT PLEASE.
NINE FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING SENATORS
NAME IS YEAH CONDO AND I'M IN
STRONG OF ISSUE FIVE TIMES
BEFORE PRIME SURVIVOR. ON BEHALF
OF COMMUNITIES SCHOOL IN CHAMP
ARE THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE'RE NEXT PLEASE. NINE
TWENTY THREE YOUR LONG IS OPEN
PLEASE GO. HELLO MY NAME IS
RUBEN IT'S NOSE I'M PLAYING IN
FRONT SUPPORT OF ISSUE FIVE MORE
REPORT N SURVIVORS ON BEHALF OF
THE MARKETS ON THE LOS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU FOR
CALLING NEXT PLEASE. NINE
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MENTION
COMMUTERS MAINLY TRANSAMERICA I
AM CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR
MORE RESOURCES THANK YOU VERY
VERY ON THE HALF OF THEIR FOR.
HOW COALITION IN YOU THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. NINE ELEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE IS YET OKAY
AND I WAS PREDICT SERVICES
EXPRESSING STRONG SUPPORTER ITEM
NUMBER ONE WE BELIEVE IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT EVEN
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC WELCOME
THANK YOU AND YOUR POVERTY WITH
INCREASE IN WAGE AND HOUR ISSUES
WERE INCREASING ALMOST THAT'S
WITHIN CREEPING. IN THE
COMPLEXITY OF THE ISSUES THAT
INCREASING FUNDING TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES IS CRITICAL AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS
MATTER. THANK FOR ALL THE WORK
THAT YOU DO A NEXT PLEASE. NINE
FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING
MANAGER MY NAME IS CARLA
MARTINEZ AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF A SCRIPTURE BY RICH
BASED ON STRONG YOUTH WILL BE.
WHERE ARE RIGHT- RESEARCHERS AND
MADE IN DEFINITE DO NEED MORE
ARE REPUBLIC THAT OPPORTUNITIES
FOR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU. NOW MODERATOR. NINE FIFTY
TWO YOUR IS OPEN GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS DAVE EVAN AND
I'M CALLING ON THE OF ALL OF THE
AND THEN ORANGE COUNTY IN THE
FORTY ISSUE NUMBER. AND I ALSO
WRITE A CORPORATE ISSUE NUMBER
EIGHT THAT I AM MORE. CRISIS AND
HOMELESS NOW. DOES REGARDING OUR
AND I'M OFFA GRADUATE
RIDICULOUS DEGREE PROGRAM THAT
THAT HELP PEOPLE RECOVERING FROM
HOME. SIMON THE NUMBER IN IN
NUMBER. THANK YOU FOR CALLING.
NEXT ONE THIRTY YOUR LIFE IS
OPEN GO AHEAD. I THINK HI MY
NAME IS K. I MENTION SO. OF
ISSUE FOR. THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR CALLING NEXT. I'M THIRTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS SEAN TELL
WATER HOUSE FROM LOS ANGELES AND
I'M CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT
FOR MORE RESOURCES FOR CRIME
SURVIVORS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR CALLING NEXT PLEASE. NINE
THIRTY SIX THE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS SAM FIGUEROA CALLING ON
BEHALF OF ALL LIKE AND THEN THE
AMBULANCE AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT FOR MORE RESOURCES FOR
CRIME SURVIVORS ISSUE FIVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOU NEXT PLEASE. NINE
FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MORNING
MOTHER IN ON BEHALF AS THE
JUSTICE FOLLOWING IN ORDER OF
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE WE CHRISTOPHER
FRANK THE VIBRANT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. NINE
FIFTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME AT THE AIRPORT. THAT COULD
NOT BE A LOT WHAT THE COLOR AND
I'M I'M LOOKING AT THE PORT OF
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE IN THE FUTURE
FOR. IF MILLION DOLLARS THAT'S
REPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
MODERATOR. NINE TWENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. PROBABLY MY EXPLANATION
FOLLOWING FROM LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORTER
OF ISSUE NUMBER FIVE IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT WE ARE THE
FOURTEENTH I DO SUPPORT OUR
PROVIDERS AND YET AT IMPORTANT
FOR THIS ISSUE NUMBER FIVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE. ONE
THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO GOOD
MORNING KAREN SENATORS CREATING.
VIDEO AND I AM. OR OR MORE. AND
BY THE END GIVES. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF MY TO HAVE MORE OF
WITNESSES DOING OR PER DESERVE
ONE OKAY THANK YOU GO AHEAD.
NINE TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
MORNING CARE A MEMBERS OF ALL
WITH BLACKBURN ON LAW AND
POVERTY THE BIKE OR ITEM NUMBER
ONE AND ALLOW ARTS ON MY-
OCCASION CALIFORNIA. IN ADDITION
TO YOUR WILL AND THEN EHS AND I
A LITTLE AT A AND FIFTY NOW FOR
A RECORD. AND A BIG IS WHAT DOES
WORK AND I'M- DETAINER THANK YOU
. THANK YOU. FUNDRAISER THERE
ARE NO FURTHER THANK YOU THANK
YOU MIGHT FOR ALL YOU HELP THIS
MORNING- WE'RE DONE DR TUNING
ELSE SOME. JUST THANK ALL THE IN
WHO PARTICIPATE YOU STAYED ON
THE LINE FOR- WAITING FOR YOUR
OPPORTUNITY WE REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR PATIENCE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE VERY IMPORTANT
TO US WE WANT INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE WE'VE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA FOR TODAY'S HEARING.
THANK YOU ALL. MEMBERS.